Oh, ist doch früher.
Excellent.
Moin, wer ist denn schon da, der Phippstay ist immer am Start, der Battlesheep ist auch
da.
Moin Leute, ihr wetzt nicht, glaube ich, hab gestern bei mir im Auto in dem Android, das
ist ja ein Android, wie heißt das, Android Auto ist das, was man, das Carplay Gegenstück
und Android Automotiv ist das, glaube ich, also für, also so ein Auto Betriebssystem,
also ich hab auf meinem Android Display im Auto hab ich ein Bug gefunden, dass ich in
normale Android Menüs reinkomme, das heißt von dort könnte ich jetzt beispielsweise Zertifikate
installieren und sowas, dass ich den ganzen Traffic mitlesen kann, den das Ding macht,
wenn man es ins WLAN packt und sowas, ich weiß nicht ob ich das mache, weil wer weiß,
ob das das Ding nicht irgendwie breakt auf Dauer, da hab ich keinen Bock drauf, das ist
eh etwas fragil, die Technik, beispielsweise hat er letztens auch vergessen, dass er Carplay
kann, dann ging Carplay einfach nicht mehr, tolle Dange für den Sub, war einfach Carplay
kaputt letztens, musste ich erst mal neu starten, nee, in ganzem Ernst, eigentlich nicht, ich
meine es ist ja kein Eingriff irgendwie, also folgendermaßen, also der Bug ist eigentlich
total easy auszunutzen, man muss sich per WLAN verbinden, also man sagt man möchte per WLAN
Updates installieren und in dem Menü wo man WLAN Passwörter und so eingeben kann, während
man die Tastatur offen hat um das WLAN Passport einzugeben, muss man den Hotspot ausschalten,
dann scannt er neu und erkennt der Hotspot ist nicht da und wenn man dann auf verbinden
drückt im noch offenen Keyboard Menü, also im noch offenen Menü, dann geht das nicht
richtig zu und du hast so ein halbtransparentes Fenster als Overlay und wenn man da drauf
klickt, dann kommt man ins normale Android Menü, das hab ich mehr oder weniger durch
Zufall rausgekriegt, so und dann bist du im normalen Android, Android, Auto, Motiv, WLAN
Menü und dort kannst du Zertifikate und Sachen installieren und vielleicht kommt man von
dort dann auch noch in ganz andere Menüs rein, ja zum Beispiel Files oder sowas, vielleicht
kann man da drüber sogar Sachen sideloaden oder so, hier vielen Dank für den Sub, also
ich denke nicht, dass dadurch die Garantie rippt, aber ich könnte mir vielleicht vorstellen,
dass wenn man dort ganz komische Sachen macht, dass dann Upgrades nicht mehr funktionieren
oder so, oder dass es kaputt geht beim nächsten Update, ich meine die Dinger sind ja nicht
dafür, die haben ja da keine Checks drin, ob da Custom Files oder so rumliegen.
Warte mal, ich muss mal kurz mein Handy anschließen an meinem total kaputten Lightning Kabel,
dass es mal auflädt, also wo arbeitest du eigentlich, ich bin in der Bank in Frankfurt
am Start, das habe ich ja auch schon ein paar Mal gesagt, das ist nichts Geheimes, welche
sage ich nicht, aber ja so sieht es aus, ich habe da auch schon ein paar Videos drüber
gemacht, wo man gucken kann, was ich genau mache, Massive Subscriptions hier Leute,
huge Subs, dazu kann ich bloß sagen, gestern konnte ich nicht, gestern musste ich versuchen
ein paar Sachen hin zu biegen hier daheim, zum Beispiel, dass ich von der Fiat Webseite
die Infos von meinem Auto auslesen kann und eine Home Assistant reinkriege, aber da hatte
ich doch keinen Bock, das zu bauen, ansonsten habe ich gestern nicht viel gemacht, nee also
gestern, irgendwo muss man sich ja auch mal ein bisschen ausruhen, sage ich mit 4 Tage
ich weiß manche Arbeiten, ich weiß gar nicht wie ich das früher gemacht habe, das geht
nicht, da sieht man Fahrzeugnummer und Passwort und sowas, nee das geht nicht, kann ich nicht
im Stream machen, ich kann das dann auf GitHub pushen am Ende, aber ich kann es nicht entwickeln
im Stream mit meinem Passworten Account, das funktioniert nicht, jetzt wollte ich irgendwas
sagen, habe ich vergessen, naja, ich muss mir übrigens auch mal angucken, wie das mit
dieser THG Quote, nee, wie heißt das Ding, nicht THQ THG, THG Quote ausschaut, wer es
für Anbieter da gibt, weil man kann ja mittlerweile, wenn man ein Elektroauto hat und ich glaube
auch bei einem Elektrofahrrad geht das glaube ich in gewisser Weise oder Elektroroller oder
so, geht das in bisschen kleinerer Variante auch, kannst du jetzt quasi das was du an
CO2 einsparst, kannst du quasi deine CO2 Einsparungen verkaufen an irgendwelche Umweltverschmutzer,
die dann mehr Umwelt verschmutzen dürfen für das was du nicht verschmutzt hast, das kann
man verkaufen, da gibt es bis zu 400 Euro im Jahr für und gut ich meine das nicht machen
wäre ja auch doof, wenn man schon mal, ich meine, wenn man 400 Euro kriegt, warum sollte
ich 400 Euro nicht nehmen, ja, zumal es ja nicht so ist, dass man jetzt denken könnte,
also man könnte ja denken, man könnte ja denken, wenn man das nicht verkauft seinen
quasi gesparten CO2 Anteil, dann gibt es weniger Umweltverschmutzung, weil wenn man
seinen Anteil nicht verkauft, dann kann den auch keiner raushauen, also keiner den benutzen
und CO2 raushauen, ist aber nicht so, weil alle, zumindest habe ich das gelesen, also
hier, ich weiß nicht ob das alles so ist, aber ich gehe mal davon aus, dass wenn du
das nicht selbst machst, das sind CO2 Zertifikate ja, wenn du das nicht selbst machst, ist es
nicht etwa so, dass dein CO2 Anteil verfällt und du sagst, jawoll ich habe was Gutes für
die Umwelt getan, nein, dieser CO2 Anteil kann dann glaube ich am Ende des Jahres so
gehandelt werden, nur dass du das Geld nicht kriegst, also im Prinzip ist es nicht so,
dass du sagen kannst, wenn ich es nicht verkaufe, dann gibt es das, dann wird auch keiner dieses
CO2 raushauen, ne ne, das wird auf jeden Fall rausgehauen, also es ist jetzt eigentlich
eher die Frage, greifst du das Geld ab oder nicht, also Umwelt was Gutes tun kannst du
damit nicht, ich habe keine Solaregeschichten auf dem Dach, das mache ich nächstes Jahr,
es gibt so ein paar Sachen, die ich noch machen muss, ich muss zum Beispiel mein Hoftor elektrisch
mal gucken, ob es da irgendwie so ein Video gibt, ja, aber könnte man sich tatsächlich
mal angucken, also die löten da was dran, ne, das mache ich ganz bestimmt nicht, also
ich will beispielsweise mein Hoftor elektrisch öffnen, aufmachbar machen und ich will mir
nächstes Jahr angucken, wie das mit Solar-Panels auf dem Dach aussieht, ich habe mich da schon
ein bisschen schlau gemacht, es gibt ja zum Beispiel, doch bei den Stadtwerken Hanau
ist das, irgendeine Karte oder so, da gibt es irgendeine Karte wo man gucken kann, ah
ne, das da, wie die Sonneneinstrahlung bei einem daheim ist, ich meine die Seite sieht
aus wie von 1995, das ist, da muss man sich jetzt nicht wundern, die ist halt nicht so,
ja, also sagen wir jetzt mal beispielsweise, nehmen wir mal irgendwas, nehmen wir mal die
Zeil in Frankfurt, die 1, Frankfurt, so, da kann man jetzt gucken, wie da die Sonnen,
Alter, ist diese Seite lahm, meine Güte, ja, da kann man gucken, wie da so, hier, Konsti,
da kann man gucken, wie hier die so, die Einstrahlung ist und irgendwo gibt es dann auch ein Tool,
also mal angenommen, wenn mir das hier jetzt gehören würde, irgendwo gibt es dann auch
ein Tool, da kann man, ach ne, das ist das hier, da kann man jetzt sagen, ok, ich will
jetzt hier eine Solaranlage einbauen, das ist natürlich nur so, nur so ganz grob, ja
und dann kriegst du hier ungefähr ausgerechnet, mit wie viel Sonneneinstrahlung pro Jahr man
rechnen kann, ich mein, die Seite sieht nicht schön aus, aber die funktioniert, da kannst
du hier gucken, ok, das ist also welche Himmelsrichtung zu welchen Tageszeiten und dann siehst du
hier auch, ok, Strahlungsenergie pro Quadratmeter, welche Neigung muss das sein, das ist natürlich
verdammt groß, ja, 1,2 Kilometer, 1,2 ist Quadratkilometer, Solarpanels, da bezahlst
du ein bisschen was für, zumindest, man kann jetzt auch, ich glaub, man kann sich hier
auch ausrechnen lassen, ungefähr was es kostet, also es kostet dann irgendwie schleppische
120.000 Euro oder sowas, also zumindest, die Seite ist tatsächlich echt praktisch, wenn
man mal so grob gucken will, so über den Daumen gepeilt, ob es Solarenergie auf den Dach
bringt und ich hab das bei mir daheim gemacht, also mein Standort ist gar nicht so schlecht,
zumindest auf einer Seite, da lohnt sich das auf jeden Fall, muss ich mir aber näher
nächstes Jahr im Detail angucken und dann lohnt sich das mit Elektroauto und vor allem
selbst verbrauchen halt am meisten, Einspeisen kannst du vergessen, bei Solarenergie, mein,
das kann man machen, aber das was es da gibt an Kohle ist eigentlich, ja, kannst du eigentlich,
kannst du eigentlich knicken, also das wichtigste ist, den Kram selbst zu verbrauchen.
Lieferzeit, ja es ist aktuell Lieferzeit für alles, 5-6 Monate oder länger, mein Auto hätte
ja auch bis zu 14 Monaten gebraucht, bis es lieferbar gewesen wäre, aber ich hab Glück
gehabt und hab's nach einer Woche schon gehabt, weil das in dem Fall wirklich Glück war, dass
das so funktioniert hat.
Gut, so, so sieht das aus, solartechnisch, also wer das mal bei sich ausprobieren will,
kann das hier machen, also zumindest für Hessen kann man das hier machen, für andere
Länder gibt es das bestimmt auch, so und wie gesagt, hier kann man sich dann auch ausrechnen
lassen ungefähr was da im Jahr bei rumkommt, also selbst verbrauchen ist das allerbeste
was man machen kann und ein Akku dabei sollte es sein, weil man will ja nicht unbedingt
alles immer tagsüber machen, man muss halt gucken, es gibt da in Deutschland wieder 30
Milliarden Regeln, was man beachten muss und wie man hier irgendwie was machen darf und
bis zu einem gewissen Grenzwert und bla bla bla, das ist alles nicht so einfach, zum Beispiel
hab ich bei mir, bei der Hanau Netz GmbH heißt das Ding glaube ich gefragt, Hanau Netz hier,
das ist der Netzbetreiber in Hanau, ich dachte immer das sind die Stadtwerke, das stimmt
aber nicht, die Stadtwerke haben irgendwie so eine Unterabteilung, die sich Hanau Netz
GmbH nennt und die sind dafür zuständig und wenn man ein Ladegerät anmelden will bei sich
daheim fürs Elektroauto, also das was so unter Wallbox läuft, warum heißt das eigentlich
Wallbox, wahrscheinlich weil der erste Hersteller Wallbox hieß oder so, ich weiß es gar nicht,
so wenn man sowas anmelden will, dann ist das so, dass du Ladegeräte bis 11 Kilowatt
kannst du einfach so einbauen lassen, dann musst du nur Bescheid sagen, die 22 Kilowatt
musst du dir genehmigen lassen, so und ich hab die hier angeschrieben, Hanau Netz GmbH,
wie siehts dann aus mit dem Einbau von so einem Ladegerät und da meinten sie ja, das
müsste ich dann halt mir genehmigen lassen und das geht nur, wenn sie irgendwie die
Möglichkeit bekommen das abzuschalten Remote oder sowas, also da muss man dann quasi noch
irgendwelche extra Sachen einbauen und da hab ich gesagt, nee weißt du was, scheiß
drauf, 11 Kilowatt reicht, ich mein mein Akku hat 42 Kilowattstunden, das heißt im
Endeffekt realistisch betrachtet ist das also, theoretisch ist das in 4 Stunden voll von
0 auf 100, praktisch gesehen ist es wahrscheinlich 5 Stunden oder so, aber das macht ja nix.
Weil von 0 auf 100 lädste selten, nicht Adresse liegt, hier ist nix liegt, das ist die Zeil
in Frankfurt, also wenn ich 1,2 Quadratkilometer Dachfläche hätte, hätte ich auch nichts
dagegen, aber es ist leider nicht der Fall, das ist bei mir etwas weniger, aber da kommt
auf jeden Fall einiges rum hier an der Stelle, was für ein Auto ich mir geholt hab, ich
hab mir den hier geholt, guck da, kann man den nicht mal drehen hier, das ist ja billig,
0, 4500 E, am Ende hab ich bezahlt 25.200 Euro für, weil erstens gibt es ja noch Umweltprämie
bis Ende des Jahres und zweitens war es ein Vorführauto, was es auch schon mal ein bisschen
billiger gemacht hat.
Ja der Agila, der ist nicht mehr Agile, der steht jetzt in der Garage, weiß nicht was
ich mit dem mach, ob wirklich verkaufen kann man das nicht, ich mir, ja du kannst das Auto
nicht flaschen gescheit, was du machen kannst, das hab ich am Anfang des Streams erzählt,
da waren die meisten noch nicht da, was ich gestern rausgefunden hab, ich hab einen Bug
gefunden in meinem Onboard Entertainment System, wie man dort über den WLAN Dialog ins normale
Android Menü reinkommt, wie lange hast du bekommen bis die Instant, Instant, weil das
war ein Vorführauto, das heißt das war schon alles abgezogen, das war schon quasi mit
dabei, da musste ich gar nichts mehr beantragen, ja driften kann man damit auch nicht mehr
gescheit, weil du hast keine Handbremse, achso ne Firmenwagen hab ich nicht, du hast keine
richtige Handbremse mehr in dem hier, also der hat, weiß nicht ob man es hier irgendwo
sieht, weiß nicht ob man es irgendwo von innen sieht, hier das ist die Handbremse dieser
Schalter, also du hast nur noch einen Knopf für die Handbremse, so richtig driften Handbremse
ist da nicht, achso, der fällt um wenn du mit dem driftest wahrscheinlich, ja wie gesagt
also ich hab rausgekriegt wie ich ins Android, wie ich ins Android WLAN Menü komme, über
die WLAN Settings von meinem Auto und vielleicht komm ich über das WLAN Android Menü noch
woanders hin, also Zertify Custom, Custom Zertify Karte kann man darüber installieren
wenn ich mal ein Traffic mit sniffen will oder so, aber vielleicht komm ich da auch
irgendwie in andere Menüs, im Zweifelsfall kann man vielleicht sogar APKs sideloaden
oder so, ja aber ich verwende die, also normalerweise verwende ich die gar nicht, weil die geht
automatisch an wenn du auf Parken gehst und die geht automatisch aus wenn du Gas gibst,
also eigentlich brauchst du es wirklich nur wenn es irgendwie rollt und am Berg oder
ne, wobei das macht der auch automatisch, also ich wüsste eigentlich gar nicht jetzt
wann ich die Handbremse von Hand mal an und aus machen würde, wann würde ich denn das
machen, keine Ahnung, hat jetzt gar nichts ein, weil man das braucht, ich weiß nicht
was die Hold Funktion sein soll, der hat eh, Leute ich bin echt begeistert von meinem Auto,
ja der hat ein Regensensor, da geht der Scheibenwischer automatisch an, der lenkt rüber wenn du auf
die Spur zufährst, also auf den Streifen zufährst, der hat so viel Krempel drin, wo ich gar nicht
wusste dass es das gibt, ja du kannst irgendwie Tempo einstellen für die Autobahn, du kannst
einstellen den Abstand zum Vormann halten und sowas, fuck alter, keine Ahnung, keine
Ahnung, also wenn ich automatisch Gas gebe geht die Handbremse raus, ja man kann es relativ
easy ausschalten, du musst zweimal auf den Knopf drücken, dann ist es aus, so, so sieht
es aus, ja wahrscheinlich, ich wüsste jetzt zwar nicht wie man das nennt, aber wahrscheinlich
nennt man das dann Hold Funktion, also bei Youtube, Youtube mal die Chance geben, was
haben wir denn hier, nichts was ich merke, Homelab, oh ne Moment, stopp, stopp, stopp,
nein, nein, nein, das gucken wir heute nicht an, das ist der Kerl mit 5 Kubernetes Clustern
daheim, Raspberry Pi als Mini PC im Alltag, naja, das kann man machen wenn es sein muss,
aber viel Spaß hat man damit wahrscheinlich nicht, du kannst, du kannst nicht pennen,
weil wenn du, wenn du die Hände nicht auf dem Lenkrad hast, dann nervt es dich, also
wenn du die Hände vom Lenkrad nimmst, dann fängts an zu piepsen, der hat wirklich total
viel Zeug drinnen, wo ich jetzt erstmal das der Reihe nach alles raus kriegen muss, du
hast einen Calibra, da wäre ich ja nie drauf gekommen jetzt, chat hättet ihr das gedacht,
also das war kaum zu vermuten ehrlich gesagt, schau mal was mit Traffic gemacht, ja sogar
im Stream, guck mal, Archiv, was, wir haben das bestimmt falsch geschrieben, das kann,
ach ne ich hab's nicht im Titel genannt, ich hab's irgendwie Reverse Proxy oder so genannt,
das könnte mit Traffic gewesen sein oder mit Kaddi, ich weiß es nicht, aber wir haben,
wir haben schon ein paar Sachen oder vielleicht haben wir irgendwie, ich glaub, das haben
wir mit Traffic gemacht oder, ja da, guck da siehst du es doch, alter guck mal, das Archiv
speichert sogar, wo man stehen geblieben ist beim Player alter, richtiger Fiveheader Kram,
was er da gebaut hat, Massive Big Brain, ne hab ich mir noch nicht angeguckt, was gab's
denn, ich hab gehört es gab Ordner Strukturänderungen, gab's sonst noch irgendwas spannendes, gibt's,
wie sieht's mit Version 1 aus, gibt's das irgendwann noch mal, wo sind wir da grad stehen geblieben,
wo sind wir da grad, Next Gedöns, ja, irgendwas spannendes, wo man das nachgucken kann außer
in den Comments, was willst du denn wissen, also was hast du denn vor, so Youtube, ich
hab zwar schon ein paar Videos auf, aber guck mal, vielleicht, vielleicht kriegen wir noch
irgendwas empfehlen, wo ich mir empfohlen, wo ich mir denke, jawoll, das will ich jetzt
unbedingt gucken.
Das empfiehlt er uns, das haben wir schon längst gesehen, das Video war nice, da konnte
ich mich darüber auslassen, wie eklig ist es selbst Netzwerkkabel zu machen.
Mac Guy vs PC Guy vs Linux Guy, was, da hab ich mich ja selbst schon oft genug zu ausgelassen,
spielst du irgendwas, jetzt, ja, aber jetzt nichts irgendwie, wo ich sagen würde, das
ist was, was ich monatelang grind oder so, ich sag mal, irgendwelchen Kleinkram auf Steam,
so irgendwas, was ein paar Stunden geht, also keine großen Titel aktuell, also ich glaub,
das bekannteste, was ich in letzter Zeit gespielt hab, ist Stray, das mit der Katze, ansonsten,
es gibt halt wenig Games, die so richtig geil finden aktuell, Moin Blue Skies, ja Netzwerkkabel
selbst machen ist wirklich painstamp, ich weiß gar nicht, warum man das, warum man das machen
will, weil ich mein mal ernsthaft, fertige Netzwerkkabel kosten jetzt ja auch nicht wirklich
viel, ja, du kannst sogar irgendwie, was weiß ich, nimmst du mal, genau nimmst du mal
irgendwas, was wirklich ordentlich ist, Farbe, kannst du gar so ein Set kaufen schon in Farbe,
so, also, bevor ich mir 20 Kabel selber krimpe, dann kauf ich mir lieber hier, was fertig
ist, die wahrscheinlich sogar noch besser sind als meine selbst gekrimpten.
Ja, aber wo haste das, also ich mein, wir haben das ganze Haus hier, wurde renoviert
und so, da hab ich gleich Kabel mitlegen lassen, dort wo ich sie haben will, einzige, was ich
hätte beim Haus renovieren vielleicht mehr darauf achten sollen ist, dass noch an mehr
Stellen Leerrohre reinkommen, ja, zum Beispiel, dass ich vor meinem Technikraum auch direkt
noch ein neues Kabel in den Keller schieben kann durch das Rohr oder besser in Flur komme
oder sowas, ja, das hätte ich ein bisschen mehr darauf achten sollen, aber gut, man,
ist jetzt halt wie es ist, ist das mein nächstes Laptop, ehrlich gesagt, ist mir das ziemlich
egal, ich hab letztens irgendwo ein Newsartikel gelesen oder ein Artikel gelesen auf irgendeiner
Newsseite, wo einer erzählt hat, er benutzt jetzt ein altes Thinkpad von 2012 und das
ist viel geiler als alles Neue, da hab ich mir auch gedacht, alter Cringe, ist es mit
Sicherheit nicht, das einzige, was die alten Thinkpads hatten, die hatten mechanische Display-
Scharniere, das war nicht schlecht, ja, also wenn du zum Beispiel so ein T400 irgendwas
hattest und mal hinten am Display guckst, guck, die hatten tatsächlich noch Metall zwischen
Display und Rahmen, ich denke mal, dass das heute wahrscheinlich alles Plastik ist, was
die Alternative ist, Plastik, ach, ich hab nicht, ich hab Mechanisch gesagt, nein, Metall
meine ich, Mechanisch sind die logischerweise alle, Metall, die Neuen haben bestimmt alle
Plastik, die Neuen sind auch mit Metall, weiß aber nicht, wie aktuell das ist, kriegt bei
der Benamung nicht durch, ja, das passt gut zu den Herstellern, wird immer ein bisschen
gefaked.
Seit ich mein neues Auto hab, ist mir auch mal aufgefallen, wie dumm Nummernschildhalterungen
sind, da gibt es ja auch wieder acht verschiedene Varianten oder so, ich wollte das Nummernschild
raus machen, hab erst mal überhaupt nicht gecheckt, wie ich das Ding aufkrieg, dabei
ist es ganz einfach, weil man weiß, wie es geht, hab ich im Video geguckt, wie man Nummernschild
aus der Nummernschildhalterung macht auf YouTube, ja, gibt ja für YouTube alles Video, das hab
ich geguckt, mit dem Unterschied, dass keines der Sachen, die er in diesem Video gezeigt
hat, mit meinem Nummernschildhalter übereinstimmt, ich hab es nicht abgekriegt, und dann hab
ich selbst einfach ein bisschen dran rumgezerrt, und dann ist mir aufgefallen, wie einfach
das ist, eigentlich abzukriegen, wenn man weiß, wie es geht, was für ein Aufkleber,
kann man das festkleben?
Und du meinst das Nummernschild als Aufkleber, wusste ich gar nicht, dass das gibt, warum
nutzt du eigentlich für so was wie YouTube die VM, das ist nicht die VM, wie kommst
du drauf, dass es die VM ist, oder war deine Frage, warum ich nicht die VM benutze, also
ich benutze nicht die VM, weil kein Hardware-Decoding für Videos, achso, ja, ja, genau, so siehst,
Windows, Host, Linux, VM, naja, gut, schauen wir uns mal an, was können wir uns denn, wir
lassen uns mal eine Runde LevelCapturebaiten, LevelCapturebaiten ist am Anfang immer, was
erzählt, Bad News for Battlefield, der schwankt auch wöchentlich, oder, der schwankt zwischen
Bad News for Battlefield und Huge Changes Coming to Battlefield, das ist bei ihm immer
so eine Sache oder das andere, cool, nur so zum Vergleich, was hatten wir letztes Jahr,
was hatten wir, nicht letztes Jahr, was hatten wir letzte Woche, ok, was hatten wir letzte
Woche, gar nichts, ok, Easter Egg Confirmed New Map, naja, gut, richtig, der wöchentliche
PUBG-Bait ist angesagt jetzt, Death Operator, 16 Monats, Massive Sub-Cription, Dankeschön,
ja, Huge, Proc-Sub, ja, ich weiß auch nicht, ich hab mir Season 2, Leute, habt ihr Battlefield
2042 Season 2 gespielt, lohnt sich das, die neue Container Field Map, ich hab's immer
noch nicht installiert, vielleicht sollten wir das heute Abend mal im Stream machen,
da arbeiten doch nur die Azubis an dem Game, nein, nein, nein, laut DICE und EA arbeitet
das komplette DICE-Team dran und sie brauchen halt ein Jahr dafür, drei Kisten auf die
Maps zu stellen, ja, ich benutze Vmware Workstation, das findest du bei allen möglichen Key-Shops
und sonstigen Sachen relativ billig, direkt bei Vmware würd ichs mir nicht kaufen, da
kostet es ja mittlerweile 240 Euro oder sowas, weil selbst bei Amazon, selbst bei Amazon
findest du das relativ billig, License, ja, oh oder auch nicht, Windows Vollversion, was,
ok bei Amazon anscheinend doch nicht mehr, oh ja viel zu teuer, also ich weiß nicht
was ich dafür bezahlt hab, 14 Euro oder 14 Dollar oder sowas, ich wo das herkommt, juckt
mich auch nicht, solange es über Amazon verkauft wird, geh ich davon aus, dass das alles seine
Ordnung hat, ich kann jetzt ja schlecht nachgucken, wer das wo mal wann wie gedruckt hat, genauso
wenn ich mir ne Hose bei Amazon bestell, kann ich jetzt schlecht nachgucken, in welchem Land
das in Kinderarbeit hergestellt wurde, also dann schauen wir mal, lass uns mal debaten,
was LevelCaps sagt, Halo Infinite failing, na von den Spielzahlen her, hatte schon lange
keine super krassen Dinger mehr, guck mal, ich mein, das hat weniger als Battlefield 2042,
das musste er erst mal schaffen, aber zum Vergleich, na gut aktuell kam ja auch gerade
wieder das Season 2 raus, aber na ungefähr, nee tatsächlich, es hat ja doch 24, also sagen
wir mal so ungefähr gleich viel und witzigerweise wurde ja von Battlefield 2042 die Schuld,
ein bisschen auf Halo geschoben, dass es nicht gespielt wird, was halt kompletter Schwachsinn
ist, was du wahrscheinlich dort in irgendeiner Aktionärsetzung erzählen kannst, um deinen
eigenen Arsch zu retten, aber mit der Realität dürfte es nicht allzu viel zu tun haben, das
Spiel war halt einfach kacke, das wollte man wahrscheinlich einfach nicht sagen, dass
das Spiel kacke war,
ich hab keine Ahnung, ich wüsst doch nicht mal, wie sowas aussieht, weil die Leute alle
weg sind, die gute Maps machen können, oder die es nicht mehr testen und keine Zeit haben,
wahrscheinlich Kombination aus allen möglichen, aber ganz davon abgesehen, ich denke, dass,
wenn du fähige Modder nimmst und die das machen lässt, die würden das besser hinkriegen
aktuell, guck mal Leute, ich hab so viele Taps, dass ich meinen Tab fast nicht mehr track und
dropen kann, das musst du auch erst mal hinkriegen, ok schauen wir uns das mal an, also Level
Capture Bait, nun ja, es bringt New Life, ich würde eher sagen, es bringt altes Life,
vielleicht mal für 2 Wochen weg, haben sie wieder alle weg, Alter, diese Container Mann,
warum bestehen die Battlefield 42 Maps, irgendwie zur Hälfte aus Containern, das ist doch nicht
möglich, und ich meine, das ist eine neue Map, haben die das Schiff von D-Rail oder
wie die Map, nee, wie heißt die Map, genommen und einfach blau anstatt rot gemacht, ihr müsst
mal gucken, ob immer noch 17 auf den Containern überall draufsteht, Alter, ich glaube, das
ist eine neue Map, diese Container Mann, was ist das für ein Map Design, Alter, haben
die sich wirklich gedacht, yep, wir machen einfach einen leeren Raumstellen Container
rein, so muss das sein auf einer guten Map, nein, wirklich, das ist ja nicht so, als hätte
man das nicht 3 Wochen nach Release schon gesagt,
Ich meine, ich habe es vor Release gesagt, und alle haben zu mir gesagt, nein, nein, Max,
das kann überhaupt nicht sein, Server Browser gehört zu Battlefield und die können da gar
nichts irgendwie machen, weil Server Browser, und ich habe vor Release schon, keine Ahnung,
ein Jahr vor Release gesagt, das sinnvollste, was sie machen könnten, aus ihrer Sicht,
um die Sachen so durchzusetzen, ist kein Server Browser, und haben alle gesagt, nein, nein,
das kann überhaupt nicht sein, und bam, spielt kein Server Browser, ach ja, Battlefield
Hardcore Fanboy Verfechter sagen, selbstverständlich hat dieses Spiel einen Server Browser, weil
du in Portal einen Server Browser hast, ja geil, mit nicht-persistenten Servern, die
sich immer wieder selbst löschen, selbstständig, wenn da keiner drauf ist, und in einem Modus,
den keiner mehr spielt, so geil, perfekt, Selfmade, alles, danke für den Sub, sag mal,
ich meine, seriously, guckt euch mal das hier an, in der Map, das sieht legit aus, wie damals
im Half-Life Editor, wenn du deine ersten Gehversuche gemacht hast, genau so sieht das
aus, was ist, das ist ja schon fast frech, wenn das überall so aussieht, ich hab die
neue Map ja noch nicht gespielt, vielleicht machen wir das heute Abend, das ist ja schon
fast frech, das als neue Map zu verkaufen, aber gut, ich meine, vielleicht ist es jetzt
so wirklich nur dieser eine Teil, der so aussieht, ich meine, immerhin, es sind rote Container,
die ganzen Copy-Paste-Container auf den Maps sind ja grüne Container, und graue Container,
ich hab immer wieder gespielt, aha, aha, aha, aha, aha, aha, aha, aha, aha, aha, aha,
aha.
Also, ich meine, Microsoft hat ja, du hast ja fast schon mittlerweile keinen Grund mehr,
so wirklich, wenn dich irgendwie ein paar dieser Games interessieren, keinen Game Pass mehr
zu haben, also die buttern da schon ordentlich rein bei Microsoft.
Na eher nicht, na in Warzone vielleicht, Zulul wurde gelöscht, hast du das nicht mitgekriegt,
Zulul, die ganzen Zulul-Emotes wurden gelöscht, weil Black Facing, ist wirklich so, ist wirklich
so, Zulul wurde gelöscht, weil Zulul-Emotes waren ja hier, also generell diese Emotes
sind ja eh schon, ich meine, eigentlich das Ursprungs-Emote war ja mal, falls sich da
irgendjemand noch dran erinnern kann, das Ursprungs-Emote ist ja ein Bild von Total
Biscuit, der leider nicht mehr lebt, seit ein paar Jahren schon, das war YouTube Content
Creator, StarCraft Caster, so das war ja das ursprüngliche Bild, so und Twitch musste
das nachmalen, weil Total Biscuit anscheinend nicht die Rechte an seinem eigenen Gesicht
hatte, also sprich, die Rechte an diesem Bild lagen nicht bei Total Biscuit, sondern beim
Fotograf, irgendwie so, ich erinnere mich dunkel, deswegen musste Twitch, um dieses
Emote zu übernehmen, das Bild nachmalen, so und irgendwelche Leute haben dann dieses
Bild genommen und quasi mit schwarzer Hautfarbe gemacht, und das war dann Zulul, und irgendwann
war, guck ob ich das Emote noch irgendwo habe, irgendwo habe, hier Zulul, so sah das
aus, das war Zulul und irgendjemand oder irgendwelche Gruppierungen kamen dann auf die Idee, das
ist ganz schlimm und böse rassistisch, weil Black Facing und darauf hin haben FFZ und
Better Twitch TV alle diese Emotes, die Black gefacen Emotes entfernt, ups, jetzt habe ich
den Chat zugemacht, MonkaS, aber ich war eh unten, es gibt Sachen, die kann ich nicht
ganz nachvollziehen, aber ich muss mich der Sache halt, ja was soll ich machen, meine
Emotes sind halt weg, ich kann es nicht ganz verstehen, aber Emotes kannst du vergessen,
echt, wirklich, die haben aber, dann ist es bald weg, dann ist es bald weg, die löschen
das gerade, also wenn die es finden, wird es gelöscht, es uploaden wahrscheinlich immer
wieder neue Leute, ja, aber, so, gucken wir mal weiter, also das ist der Hintergrund, warum
es Zulul nicht mehr gibt, oder mal, hat dieses Spiel so viele Spieler tatsächlich, dass
es, dass man eine jährliche quasi Star Citizen Messe oder so machen kann, wie viele Spiele,
ist das auf Steam, ist das auf Steam, nee, oder, weil ich vorhin so, oder, ah nee, Tags,
nee ist es nicht, mich würden nämlich die aktuellen Spielzahlen wirklich mal interessieren,
hat jemand eine Ahnung, gibt es das, Star Citizen Player Count, Star Citizen Server Population
Player Count, ja, zeig mal her, was, im Leben nichts, das hat doch keine halbe Million täglicher
Spieler, wirklich, wo haben die das her, und was machen die da, die ganzen, die ganzen
Tag drin, ja, daily, doch, also das sind halt quasi alle Spieler, die im Tag mal eingeloggt
werden, ja, ich finde es auch hardly believable, Reddit Engagement Data, naja, naja, ok, ich
wollte gerade auch sagen, das kann ich mir, kann ich mir schlecht vorstellen, also, ja,
wie viel haben sie denn, wie viel haben sie denn jetzt eigentlich, Quatsch, ok, also
die geben keine offiziellen Spielerzahlen raus, wie es aussieht, und meistens, das
haben wir zumindest bei World of Warcraft gelernt, meistens, sobald aufgehört wird,
offizielle Spielerzahlen rauszugeben, sind die Spielerzahlen, fallen die Spielerzahlen
oder sind nicht gut, ja, die haben aufgehört, WoW-Spielerzahlen rauszugeben, als sie richtig
krass gedroppt sind, haben seitdem nicht wieder angefangen, also, was mich interessieren würde
ist, wie gut die Klassik-Server laufen.
Er hat keine Augen, oder, warum hat er keine Augen, das sieht irgendwie MonkaS aus, haben
die vergessen, oder wie ist das?
Ich meine, das, dass irgendjemand wirklich handfeste Sachen zu Battlefield hat, Battlefield
7 hat, ich bezweifle es, zumal DICE, ja, bei Battlefield 2042 schon äußerst spärlich
war, mit Leuten, die es im Vorfeld sehen durften, und, wenn überhaupt, dürfen das nur die
Leute sehen, die halt absolut Dauerarschkriechen machen, ich hab's bei diesem Anspiel, ich
kann's nicht oft genug sagen, weil ich's einfach zu affig fand, ich hab's bei diesem Anspiel-Event
gesehen, die mich, by the way, wahrscheinlich nie wieder einladen werden, weil ich das Spiel
so gebashed habe, aber ich sag halt über das Game, was ich über das Game denke, und
ich bin halt als Battlefield-Fan einfach maßlos enttäuscht gewesen, zumindest, bei diesem
Anspiel-Event war halt auch schon wieder richtig cringe, ja, also, das war ja ein paar Tage,
zwei Wochen, oder, ich weiß nicht mehr, war ne Weile, bevor die Beta gestartet ist, gab's
ja so ein Anspiel-Event, und, es wurde so rumgeschleimt, die ganze Zeit, gerade im englischsprachigen
Chat, deswegen, mich wundert es nicht, dass, wenn das das einzige Feedback ist, was sie
bekommen haben, mich wundert es nicht, dass die wirklich gedacht haben, sie haben das
geilste Spiel aller Zeiten entwickelt, ich hab direkt in Chat geschrieben, Wetter nervt,
halt im deutschen Chat, das liest aber wahrscheinlich eh keiner, weil, in diesem Anspiel-Event
war gefühlt, in jeder Runde Wirbelsturm, fünf Mal, aber das haben sie wahrscheinlich
einfach nur hochgedreht, dass man das sieht, naja, was, Jack-Frax, den hab ich ja ewig,
wusst gar nicht, dass es den noch gibt, gibt es eigentlich noch, Moment, gibt es eigentlich
noch Frankie, und, gibt's den Dude noch?
Ne, oder, sie, doch, tatsächlich, äh, was soll ich suchen, realistik, keine Ahnung,
das vor zwei Wochen, mal gucken, was da rauskommt, ich glaub, da an der, also zum aktuellen Zeitpunkt
nichts, by the way, wie kann es überhaupt schon Details zu Battlefield 7 geben, Leute,
ich dachte, komplett DICE arbeitet daran, Battlefield 2042 zu fixen, sagen sie doch selbst, wie
kann es denn an Battlefield 7 überhaupt schon geben, oder zumindest schon was dazu bekannt
sein, das geht doch gar nicht, das, das kann nicht sein, ich glaub denen das natürlich
auch, wenn die das sagen, ja, und die brauchen natürlich auch ein halbes Jahr, um drei Kisten
auf der Map zu platzieren, aber, jetzt widerspricht sich ja schon ein bisschen selbst alles, ja,
Moment, Moment, sollte nicht sowas wie, wie, Assasin's Creed, sollte nicht irgendein Best
of Assasin's Creed kommen, jetzt, Assasin's Creed United, oder sowas, Assasin's Creed,
ne, äh, wie ist denn das, Infinite, eh, hier Infinity, Infinity, nicht United, sollte,
ok, was auch immer, keine Ahnung, Chat, Moment, wir müssen kurz IT Support machen, wie ging
das nochmal mit SSH, dass man vor, von einem Server auf den anderen Server eine Verbindung
aufbaut, also Tunneln, minus groß Y, äh, nicht Y, Y ist Screensharing, J, groß J,
das ist X-Forwarding, äh, sorry, minus groß J, musst du machen, und dann hier gibst du
den, also es ist, SSH minus J, Bloop, Punkt, Jumphost, Punkt, komm, und dann ist es, Kekkel,
Add, äh, Target, IP, so, ich hätte aber tatsächlich mal Bock auf ein neues Assasin's
Creed Game, was nicht so, man sieht nichts, wie man sieht nichts, ich hab's da oben in
die Adressleiste geschrieben, natürlich sieht man das, ähm, ich hätte tatsächlich mal
wieder Bock auf ein, auf ein ordentliches Assasin's Creed, allerdings, die letzten
Assasin's Creed Teile, also Valhalla hab ich mir beispielsweise gar nicht gekauft,
obwohl ich mega Bock hatte drauf, weil ich eben auf so Viking-Settings stehe, aber das
ging mit Unity schon finde ich, mit Unity hat's angefangen in die falsche Richtung
zu gehen, dass die Sachen quasi so krass voll gekleistert waren, mit 0 nach 15 Kisten und,
und, und Sammel, ich mein, du hattest in Assasin's Creed 2 auch schon Sammelfedern
oder so, aber das war noch irgendwo überschaubar und auch cool gemacht, weil du dann die ganze
Map erkunden musstest, in den, ab Unity hast du halt irgendwelche Kisten, wo unsinnige Sachen
drin sind, und das überall, also eines der, der krassesten, der krassesten Dinger war
in Assasin's Creed Odyssey, auch die Level-Mechanik und sowas, ich war, ich war da, also die ganzen
RPG-Elemente, finde ich, waren zu, sind zu stark in den Vordergrund getreten, irgendwann
mal bei Assasin's Creed, Odyssey, Map, du hattest ja eine ganze Map, also einen ganzen
Inselteil, hier dieses ganze Inselteil, Alter, die Map war einfach nur groß, um groß zu
sein, nicht weil es irgendwie sinnvoll war, und ich hätte tatsächlich mal wieder Bock
auf ein Assasin's Creed, man, die Story ist meistens ganz okay, ich, jetzt mal, übrigens
mal eine Frage, Frage an euch, welches Assasin's Creed hat euch am besten gefallen, Story-technisch,
also ich muss sagen, ehrlich gesagt, Assasin's Creed 3, das mit Connor und seinem Vater,
und Kokona, Kokona-Style, Assasin's Creed 2 war auch nicht schlecht, ja, aber, aber
ich muss sagen, mir hat tatsächlich, Story-technisch, Assasin's Creed 3 am besten gefallen, naja,
zumindest, ich hätte tatsächlich Bock mal wieder auf ein Assasin's Creed, was sich
so auf Assasin's Creed fokussiert, und weniger Open-World-RPG mit unendlich Generic-Computer-generated-Content,
stimmt, Black Flag, Black Flag hab ich aber nie durchgespielt, Black Flag hat sich, hat
sich, ähm, hat sich Story-technisch für mich jetzt nicht so, hab ich jetzt gar nicht
so großartig in Erinnerung, keine Ahnung, nee, was, hast du eigentlich jemals Alpha
4 Games in Real Life gesehen, nö, nö, eigentlich nicht, ich hab auf der Gamescom einige Leute
getroffen, die letzten Jahre über, gut, die alle letzten Jahre hier war ich ja gar nicht
mehr da, waren, waren alle möglichen Leute dabei, aber Alpha 4 Games war nicht dabei.
Damals konnte man sich sogar noch mit Montana Black kurz unterhalten auf der Gamescom, ohne
dass dir die Horde, die Horde 2000, 2000 Mann, stärker, 12- bis 16-Jähriger nicht blattgetrampelt
hat, ja, also, das muss ja dieses Jahr wirklich krass gewesen sein, alter, naja, aber Gamescom
muss ich sagen, vor ein paar Jahren fand ich das immer sehr nice, einfach weil's mal so
komplett andere Welt war, so mitten im Jahr mal komplett andere Welt für ne Woche, fand
ich wirklich nice, vor allem halt auch, du musstest halt Termine im Vorfeld machen, dass
du nicht so ewig anstehen musstest und dass du die Sachen in Ruhe angucken kannst, das
war halt, Planungsaufwand war schon nicht unerheblich für die Gamescom, gerade wenn man sowas nicht
hauptberuflich macht, ja, deswegen war ich froh, dass ich das mit dem, mit dem Mesh damals
gemacht hab, dass wir das zusammen geplant haben, also sprich, wir haben unterschiedliche
Leute, Termine abgesprochen und sowas, das war ganz gut, ansonsten fand ich die Gamescom
wirklich nice, aber ganz im Ernst, zum Spielen muss man nicht auf die Gamescom und seit
ein paar Jahren geh ich da auch nicht mehr hin, weil es war früher schon krass voll
und es ist noch voller und die einzigen Tage, also der Pressetag ist ja eh das einzige,
wo du dich da halbwegs sinnvoll drauf bewegen kannst, ähm, und der Rest geht auch nur,
wenn du Termine hast und das ist halt so unsinnig eigentlich dort vor Ort zu sein, weil du erfährst
nichts neues, das was du anspielen kannst ist auch selten irgendwie was, ja wie soll
ich sagen, also was du nur da sehen kannst, also wirklich bringen tut es nix, ich weiß
noch, also ich wurde ja einmal, also ich wurde mehrfach, aber einmal war witzig, wurde ich
ja auf der Gamescom erkannt, und zwar war das bei Battlefield Hardline noch, also könnt
ihr euch ja vorstellen, das war, ist ein paar Jahre her, war Battlefield Hardline, da gab
es oben im Pressebereich gab es schon so ein Testet mal den neuen Spielmodus Event, das
war irgend so ein komisches CS Style Permadeath Spielmodus, weiß gar nicht wieder genau
heißt, in Hardline hat danach nie jemand gespielt, und sind wir halt da aufgekreuzt zu unserem
Termin, Hardline war das Polizei Ding, genau, sind wir aufgekreuzt zu unserem Termin, haben
die gesagt, ja ja nice, hier kommt rein, ähm, setzt euch hierhin, fünf Leute da, fünf
Leute da, also zwei Teams gegeneinander, und mein Team war, wie es halt immer so gewesen
ist, war richtig schlecht, wir haben so krass gesackt, alter, wobei ich sagen muss, ich
hab's jetzt auch nicht gecarried oder so, also, der Felix war ziemlich gut, erinnere
ich mich noch dran, aber, ähm, ich hab auch übelst reingesackt, ja, die, aber, wisst
ihr, alter Leute, wisst ihr wie die Maus Sensitivity eingestellt war an diesem Test, an diesem
Testspielrecher, das war wirklich, du hast die Maus zwei Zentimeter bewegt, und hast
500 360s gemacht, das war irgendwie was, was ich, 20.000 DPI und High Sense oder so, also,
ich musste, weil ich nicht an den Maus Settings rumdoktern wurde, ich musste die Sense irgendwie
auf 0,01 oder so stellen, dass es überhaupt funktioniert hat, weißt du, naja, zumindest,
ich hab dann halt, ich hab dann so ein bisschen vor mich hingeflamed, also, alter Leute, wir
sacken ja richtig krass, warum kacken wir so ab, und anscheinend muss ich, ähm, zu viele
Wörter benutzt haben, die ich in Videos auch sonst benutze, weil als wir dann rausgegangen
sind und auf der Rolltreppe runter waren, stand hier, stand jemand neben mir, also stand jemand
hinter mir und meinte so, sag mal, bist du Max FPS, hab ich gemeint, jo, bin ich, äh,
war er erkannt, weil ich dummes Zeug gelabert hab, während diesem Anspiel-Event, also, musst
du mal vorstellen, ne, rein von, wie sich's anhört und weil ich halt quasi so vor mich
hingelabert hab, wie ich in Videos rede, da rumgestellt sind, hab ich nicht gesagt, ich
hab, ich hab, ich hab, ich hab, ich weiß, ich hab ein bisschen gemerkt, ich hab gesagt,
alter Leute, wir sacken, wie kann man so kacke sein, ich war halt auch kacke, und der hat
mich erkannt auf der Rolltreppe, also ne, der hat es ja angesprochen auf der Rolltreppe
und noch Fun-Fact, noch von der Gamescom, das hab ich wahrscheinlich schon ein paar
mal erzählt, aber wahrscheinlich haben sich alle gehört, aber ich find's einfach immer
wieder lustig, äh, G2A, ich hab ja damals Key-Shop Werbung gemacht, G2A, die kommen
ja aus, aus Russland oder so, ähm, oder, oder irgendwo, wo kommen die her? Aus Polen,
aus Polen, okay, nicht, nicht ganz, nicht ganz so weit aus der Ecke, aber, aber sag
man mal so zur Hälfte, zumindest, naja, wie, wie, wie tröglichen, wie tröglichen das
jetzt aus, wenn du so in diese Richtung gehst, aber umso weniger aufgeschlossen sind die,
was, äh, Schwule angeht, ja, und G2A denkt halt, ich bin schwul, soll sie denken, juckt
mich nicht, aber die Story find ich eigentlich ganz lustig, weil die haben uns eingeladen
zu, also die haben mich eingeladen damals auf der Gamescom, weil, als ich noch Werbung
für die gemacht hab, zu irgendeinem Vorstellungs-Event, wo sie, wo sie halt im Prinzip sich selbst,
sich selbst anpreisen wollen, wie geil sie sind, ja, und ich hab gedacht, weißt du was,
wir gehen da mal hin, weil es gibt a Goody Bag, und da war, also die Goody, die war auch
wirklich nicht, nicht schlecht, ja, also damit hab ich schon gerechnet, dass die nicht schlecht
ist, zumindest haben die geschrieben, ähm, man kann seinen Partner mitbringen, und ich
war halt mit meinem Arbeitskollegen, ehemaliger Azubi von mir, Felix war ich ja, war ich ja
auf der Gamescom, und da hab ich, mein, ja, komm, lass mal bei G2A vorbei gucken, da hab
ich denen dann unsere Mail, die Mail gezeigt, die ich mit denen geschrieben hab, dass wir
angemeldet sind, hab gesagt, ja, wir sind zwei Personen, und dann meinte sie, ja, sie findet
keine Einladung, und hier schon mal gar nicht, da hab ich das Handy rausgeholt, hab ihr die
Mail gezeigt, wo ich da mit der G2A, mit der Support-Dame da von G2A geschrieben hab, die
gesagt hat, wir sollen dann und dann zum Stand, äh, zum, zum, zum Präsentationsraum kommen,
und dann hat sie gemeint, ah ja, okay, okay, sie guckt mal nach, ah ja, passt, und dann
meint, ja, aber zwei Personen, und dann hab ich halt zu ihr so gemeint, so, jaja, this
is my partner, weil in der E-Mail stande, du kannst deinen Partner mitbringen, und da
meint sie, ah so, okay, ah ja, verstehe, verstehe, okay, und deswegen, G2A denkt, ich bin schwul
und war mit meinem Freund auf der Gamescom, aber ganz ehrlich, who cares, und noch viel
besser, die Goodie Bag war wirklich nice, da war unter anderem ein Lenovo Tablet drin,
ich mein, wir haben uns dorthin gesetzt, 45 Minuten, und haben uns G2A selbst Lobpreisungen
angehört, und haben am Ende ne Bag gekriegt mit coolen Sachen drin, und unter anderem jeder
ein Lenovo Tablet, ich mein, das war jetzt kein super krasses Highend Tablet, aber zur
damaligen Zeit ein Tablet war schon echt pock, konntest du nix sagen, also einfach für 45
Minuten Blödsinn sich anhören, da könnte ich eigentlich auch mal ein Video drüber
machen, also, wir gucken jetzt weiter.
Ab! Machen die auch jetzt die Battlefield 2042 Taktik? Irgendwelche Roadmaps rausbringen
mit kleinen Sachen und dann so tun, als hätten sie ein halbes Jahr wahnsinnig viel hingeschafft?
Moment! Forge gibt es jetzt erst! Normalerweise war Forge, aber so war dieser
Map Editor immer bei Release schon dabei, dass er bei Release nicht in Infinite dabei
war, weiß ich, aber ich dachte, mittlerweile ist er schon längst drin. Was? Coop ist Canceled?
Ne, anscheinend nicht, die sagen, die sagen, gibt's, gibt's, gibt's im November.
Achso, ja, gut, ja, gut, okay, Splitscreen Coop ist Canceled, okay, ja, das hatte Halo
immer, in Ordnung, aber, ja, aber, sagen wir mal so, 2022, ich weiß nicht, wie viele Leute
da wirklich nach der Schule sich noch treffen und Splitscreen Coop an einer Konsole am
gleichen Fernseh spielen, keine Ahnung, ich kann's schlecht einschätzen, weil bei uns
war das früher Standard, aber da war halt auch mit übers Internetspielen gerade auf
Konsolen, gab's halt nicht. Da muss man jetzt zwei Sachen sagen, Fans
complainen eigentlich aus Prinzip immer, guckt euch meine Videos an, ich hab immer
was zu meckern, ja, mal mehr und mal, also wenn das Spiel gut ist, dann an kleinen Sachen,
wenn das Spiel so sehr sackt, wie Battlefield 2042 dann, am Großen und Ganzen, aber, da
darf man nichts drauf geben, wichtig ist halt, um was da kritisiert wird, ja, weil meine
Fans sind immer am Meckern, dass ihnen irgendwas nicht gefällt, letztendlich ist es halt bei
Games wie, gut bei Halo weiß ich nicht, aber Battlefield 2042, ist es halt so, dass ganz
viele Leute über exakt das Gleiche und das über so einen langen Zeitraum meckern, dass
man halt auch selbst als Außenstehender sehen kann, dass da was dran ist, das sehen die
Fanboys auf YouTube anders, die sagen, Max, mach doch nicht immer das Spiel so schlecht,
oder früher, früher, früher die geilsten Leute und ich wette mit euch, ein paar von
euch, die jetzt im Chat sind, haben das früher auch geschrieben, sowas in der Richtung, so
nach dem Motto, Max, warum machst du Kot schlecht, oder sowas in der Richtung, ne, Max, warum
beleidigst du COD immer, oder sowas, fand ich immer geil, ja, immer wenn irgendwas war,
was halt richtig einfach blödsinnig durchdacht war, sei es von irgendwelchen Last Nice Runden
oder irgendwelchen One Shot Auto Snipern oder sowas, immer wenn du da was gesagt hast,
so damals, so die Ultra Fanboys am Start, was beleidigst du Kot, das heißt nicht Kot,
das heißt COD, genau, und es ist auch der Cobra Helikopter, die waren auch immer geil,
die halt verbessert haben, obwohl man das seit 50 Videos schon, oder seit 200 Videos absichtlich
so sagt, genau, Cobra, ey, das ist ja fast so oft schon wie GTA 5, hm, hm, hm, hm, hm,
hm, hm, hm, hm, hm, hm, hm, hm, hm, hm, hm, hm, hm, hm, hm, hm, hm, hm, hm, hm, hm, hm,
challenges for hardcore players at the end of the day though it's the same game as the 2013 release
in the $70 price tag is a lot to swallow for most players there's no doubt that the game is a hit
but it doesn't do much more than improve the graphics over the original which might not be enough for
some people to justify the cost hardcore mode is being rolled out for the already pretty tough
survival game rust hardcore will be no safe zone to rest in peacekeepers have been removed
and the local chat is limited to a hundred meter radius there's no mini map or compass so players
must be very skillful to survive alongside the hardcore mode the new update rust also includes
massive animations
hardcore mode the new update rust also includes several UI changes bug fixes and quality of life
improvements rust boasts a very impressive 130,000 peak player count on steam and continues to grow
monthly live streamer superstar ninja ended his latest broadcast on which a brother days
we don't know when he'll be back or what platform he'll be back on okay das checken wir jetzt
mal kurz ob das ob das noch so ist oder ob er gestern online war ein bisschen mal andere
leute um hatten er kein bild drin keckel vor drei tagen tatsächlich er hat seine twitter profile
gefiltert und hat seinen Namen nicht gefunden kurz nachdem alle seine sozialmedia und platform
accounts
ninja liefprofile streamer following the exodus of talent to other sites ludwig valkrie tym
the tatman dr.
Lupo and a handful of twitches other top streamers have all left the platform for greener pastures
in den vergangenen zwei Jahren.
Die Reaktion zu Ninjas Behaviour,
allerdings, ist ziemlich verbunden.
Twitch ist trotzdem noch die beste Plattform.
Viele beantworten ihn für das Verbrechen einer
Burnout, um die Publizität für seine
zukünftige Announcement zu drehen.
Die Burnout und andere mentalen
Gesundheitsprobleme sind ein
Schmerzpunkt für Content-Kreatoren
auf Twitch, YouTube, Social Media und
außerdem auf Fortnite.
Denn diese Arbeit scheint
einfach und ideal für die Zuschauer zu sein.
Aber die Realität ist, dass,
besonders auf hohem Profile-Level,
es sehr stressvoll und
eigentlich ganz einfach, oder?
Es gab ja nicht mal auch die Gerüchte,
dass er angeblich drogeabhängig ist oder so.
Ach, da wird so viel Kram erzählt,
wenn der Tag lang ist.
Facebook-Streaming, Facebook-Gaming hat
irgendwie dicht gemacht oder so,
habe ich gelesen.
Es sieht sehr ähnlich aus wie ein Steamedeck, ja.
Die Sache ist halt immer die Frage,
wie lange dieser Cremple supportet wird,
weil gerade bei Android-Tablets habe ich es
total oft gesehen, dass, ich rede von Tablets,
weil Android-Tablets ja wirklich sehr, sehr,
sehr Nischen-mäßig ist irgendwie.
Da bringen Herstellergeräte raus mit riesen
Tamtam und es gibt nicht mal ein Update.
Also, da muss man jetzt halt die Frage,
wie das da läuft.
Also, also, die haben quasi,
das hier sind die, die sie gespottet haben,
mehr gibt's nicht.
Jahre into the life cycle und es gibt so gut
wie nix.
Das gab's auch so selten, oder?
Ich meine, ich hab hier die ganzen Xbox-Spiele
noch, ne?
Ich hab, wenn ich das mal in Regal machen
würde, ich hab, ich hab irgendwie, was, ich kann
da mit ein Regal füllen mit Xbox 360-Spiele,
ich hab irgendwie, keine Ahnung, 70 Games oder
so, ist auch übelst viel Schrott dabei.
Ich hab sogar dieses Avatar-Game.
Kennt jemand noch dieses Avatar-Game für die
Xbox, was man sich nur geholt hat wegen
Gamer-Score, Xbox 360 Gamer-Score-Avatar?
Hier, das da, ich hab, ich hab sogar dieses
Avatar-Game für 1000 Easy Gamer-Score.
Du musstest einfach nur, du musstest einfach
nur da stehen und attack spammen und du hast
1000 Gamer-Score anlockt.
Das waren die einfachsten 1000 Gamer-Score
aller Zeiten.
Das Game, das ging teilweise sogar für einiges
an Geld weg, weil die Leute alle Gamer-Score
farben wollten.
Guck dir das alles, du musst einfach nur X
drücken und hast 1000 Gamer-Score gleich.
Einfach nur eine Taste drücken, easy, hier,
unlocked, unlocked, einfach nur eine Taste
drücken, fertig, guck mal.
1000 Gamer-Score, easy, in 2 Minuten 15.
Ja, das Dumme ist, an YouTube Emotes, die gilt nur
für den Channel, auf dem du die Emotes
freigeschaltet hast.
Also, guck mal, auf Twitch ist es so, wenn ihr
bei mir subscribt, dann könnt ihr meine Emotes
überall auf Twitch verwenden.
Auf YouTube, wenn ihr subscribt, könnt ihr es nur
bei mir auf Twitch verwenden.
Das ist total dumm, einfach nur.
The more months that you've been a member, any support
is greatly appreciated.
The cult survival horror sequel The Forest, Sons of the Forest,
is delayed again.
The developers at NNightGames announced that the
sequel would ship next February.
A new 12-second gameplay teaser was shared as well.
It gives fans an idea of what horrors lie ahead.
This sequel is more refined than the first game
and features better graphics and gameplay.
According to the devs, The Sons of the Forest is much
more narrative driven.
Now, if you're looking for my final opinion on the
Battlefield 2042 Season 2 content, check out this video.
Dice generally surprised me with the update and some
fast turnaround balance changes that I think you'll want to
see.
Wunderbar.
Jetzt wissen wir Bescheid.
Jetzt haben wir uns eine Runde jebaiten lassen.
Eigentlich waren wirklich viel spannendes nicht bei, oder?
So, YouTube, du hast noch mal die Chance, uns was Gutes.
Was macht eigentlich, was macht er denn so?
Haben wir schon lange nicht mehr reingeguckt.
Cheap German Lock Exceeds Okay, das muss ich mir jetzt angucken.
Wie sieht, wie sieht ein Schloss aus, dass die Expectations
Exceeded vom Lockpicking Lawyer?
Sekunde.
Spielst du aktuell was?
Ja, aber jetzt nichts, was ich monatelang kreinden kann.
Irgend so Kleinkram auf Steam, wo du in 3 bis 5 Stunden oder so
durch bist.
Also Stray ist glaube ich das bekannteste Game noch, was ich in
letzter Zeit gespielt habe.
Okay.
Moment, die Benamung ist tatsächlich irgendwie sinnvoll, oder?
Das ist irgendwie die Größe und das ist das Modell oder was auch immer.
Warum heißt es nicht Generation 2 x 40 x 116 oder so?
Das ist die
Ich werde den Pick drehen, das bedeutet, dass ich den Pick unten in den Raum brauche.
Das bedeutet, dass ich den Turning-Tool nicht da unten hin machen kann.
Obviosli.
Okay.
Klick auf 4, 2 ist Binding.
Ah, nein, okay.
Klick auf Pin 2.
Das ist das Beste.
Das bedeutet, dass wir da mehrere Spuren drin haben.
Zurück zu Pin 2.
Ein kleines Counter-Rotation und wir haben 2 gesetzt.
Counter-Rotation auf 3.
3 ist gesetzt.
Counter-Rotation auf 4.
4 ist gesetzt.
Counter-Rotation auf 5.
Und wir haben das geöffnet.
Einfach!
Lass uns das noch einmal machen.
Ich habe die Top-Of-The-Ki-Way-Tension.
Das ist der 40.000. Stift-Turner.
Und die Standard-Hook.
Diese Stiftung ist ein Teil der Genesis-Set.
Klicken auf 1.
Klicken auf 2.
Es ist ein falsches Set.
Er ist noch auf 2 gesetzt.
Einige Counter-Rotationen.
Und er ist in seiner richtigen Position.
3 ist eine andere Spule.
So ist 4.
So ist 5.
Einfach!
Okay, Leute, obwohl das mir nicht sehr lange dauerte, hat das Lock ein paar antipick-Fezien,
die sicherlich für Beginneren zwingend machen würden und es wahrscheinlich für Intermediate-Picker
eine tolle Praxis-Lock machen würden.
In jedem Fall, das ist alles, was ich hatte.
Es übernimmt die Erwartungen, weil es Picking-Protections hat.
Das Burgwächterschloss.
Es ist ja auch Burgwächter-Profi.
Da kann man das schon erwarten.
So, was geben wir uns denn jetzt als nächstes?
Zeig mal her.
AliExpress Gaming PC bestellt.
Wir rufen den dreistens China-Händler an.
Okay, ich habe jetzt schon ein paar Videos angeklickt und die meisten Videos waren ziemlich
jebait.
Das war irgendwie nicht das, was ich beim Titel erwartet habe.
Aber okay.
Warum du nicht genug Freunde hast, das kann ich euch sagen.
Also, was heißt warum?
Ich habe genug, weil das Problem ist, dass mir die meisten Menschen einfach so unglaublich
auf den Sack gehen, dass es mit denen gar nichts zu tun haben will.
Aber gut, dann gucken wir uns das jetzt an.
Okay.
Wir rufen beim China-Händler an.
Na, mal gucken.
Leute, ich halte mir vor.
Wir spulen zwischendurch vor.
Außerdem habe ich den Twitch-Chat.
Genau.
Und dann fragen wir ihn mal, was er zu den Sachen zu sagen hat.
Peter muss jetzt rangehen.
Peter von Microsoft Support.
So lange, bis Peter rangeht.
Hey Leute und herzlich willkommen bei Hardware Deals.
Es geht weiter mit Hashtag Gaming Schrott, unserem und hoffentlich eurem Lieblingsformat.
Und wie ihr sehen könnt, habe ich wieder was Interessantes mitgebracht.
Und zwar ist das hier ein Mini-PC, ein Mini-Gaming-PC.
Ein Gaming-PC auch noch.
Den ich auf die Aliexpress bestellt habe.
Ich hätte gesagt, bevor ich euch mehr zu dem Mini-PC erzähle, werden wir ihn erstmal
auspacken und schauen, ob hier überhaupt ein Mini-PC angekommen ist.
Dieses Video wird euch präsentiert von NVIDIA und den GeForce Deal Weeks bei NBB.
Auf den ersten Blick scheint es doch wirklich ein Mini-PC angekommen zu sein.
Holt ihr mal raus.
Und an der Seite steht schon i7 9750H.
Bin ich mal gespannt, weil ich glaube, ich habe eigentlich eine 10. Generation CPU bestellt.
Da ist er.
Ja, das kann man bei Aliexpress nicht so genau nehmen, was da steht und was dann am Ende ankommt.
Ein Mini-PC, wie er im Buche steht.
Also es ist wirklich sehr kompakt.
Bevor wir uns den jetzt näher anschauen, hätte ich gesagt, zeige ich euch erstmal, wie das Angebot aussah.
Das Gehäuse sieht ja auf den ersten Blick gar nicht mal so schlecht aus.
Auch wenn das hier natürlich alles Fake-Karbon-Optik ist und wahrscheinlich ganz dünnes, ganz billiges Plastik.
Aber ich meine, es sieht zumindest nicht so aus als schneidet man sich die Hände dran auf
und auch nicht als fällt er gleich auseinander.
Auf Aliexpress bestellt haben wir den 2022 Top Ton Gaming Mini-Computer Core i9 9980H i7 10750H.
Haha, ja was ist es denn jetzt für einer?
Hat er zwei CPUs drin oder wie?
Oder ist es random, was man kriegt?
Kennst du ein schönes kleines Nassgehäuse mit Platz für vier Festplatten?
Wenn du Wechselrahmen haben willst, dann nicht.
Und ohne auch nicht.
Boah, der Preis ist aber auch nicht schlecht.
Da war ich natürlich überzeugt und ich habe die Konfiguration ausgewählt mit i7 10750H und GTX 1650, 512GB NVMe SSD und 16GB DDR4 Speicher.
Die Marketing-Bilder, die haben natürlich schon direkt Schlusspropeller gemacht.
Warum ist da ein iPhone drauf?
Also was ist die Daseinsberechtigung, dass man die Größe einschätzen kann von diesem iPhone da drauf?
Soll es dann qualitativ höherwertiger wirken oder was, weil da ein iPhone drauf ist?
Marketing-Bilder, die haben natürlich schon direkt Lust auf mehr gemacht.
Ich meine, schau dich das mal an, damit kann man anscheinend ordentlich zocken.
Sehr, sehr geile Sache.
Und auch, dass es wohl eine Support-Hotline gibt, die man anrufen kann.
Peter!
Schaut mal hier, hier sind sogar die Handynummern eingegeben.
toptonminipc.com
Und wir schauen, ob wir den Top Ton Peter später auch noch anrufen müssen.
Vielleicht ist ja nicht alles an dem PC so wie bestellt.
Ich hätte gesagt, finden wir mal heraus, ob hier auch wirklich die 1650 und der i7 10750h so wie bestellt verbaut sind.
Weil auf der Verpackung, das haben wir gerade eben schon gesehen, ist zumindest ein anderer Prozessor angegeben.
Mal schauen, ob der Peter da geschummelt hat.
Das kann sein, dass der Peter uns hier...
Ach was, das wird der Peter doch nicht machen.
Das sieht auch so aus, als ob man den ganz schön einfach...
Der Peter muss halt nebenbei Leute scammen als Microsoft Gold Support.
Auf den ersten Blick sind es mal nur vier Schrauben.
Wobei, wobei, das sind ja AliExpress...
Moment, ich hab mich vertan.
AliExpress sind ja die China-Chinesen.
Der Peter vom Microsoft Support ist ja aus Indien.
So, Minipc's finde ich schon ziemlich nice, aber schau dir das mal an.
Also wenn die so aussehen, dann bin ich auf den ersten Blick mal kein großer Freund davon.
Wir haben hier nur ein RAM-Modul verbaut.
Das heißt, Single Channel, das sollte jetzt ein 16 GB Modul sein.
Naja, das wird jetzt auch nicht so viel schlechter, man.
Ich meine, das ist natürlich doof, aber das ist kein Dealbreaker.
Aber auch wenn es ein 16 GB Modul ist, bringt uns nicht viel.
Weil zwei 8 GB Module werden halt doppelt so schnell im Dual Channel wie ein 16 GB Modul.
Und das kann ganz, ganz schnell zum Flaschenhals werden.
Deswegen sollten wir allein den Peter schon vielleicht mal später anrufen, um nachzufragen, was das soll.
Hier unsere NVMe-SSDR.
Das ist dem Peter egal, solange 16 drin sind und 16 gekauft wurden.
Noch angegeben mit NVMe.
Ranxiana.
512 GB, wie bestellt.
Unsere Kühlung.
Die zwei Silent Lüfte sehen zumindest mal so aus, wie sie auch auf dem Bild geworden waren.
Ob die wirklich silent sind, das wird natürlich später erst der Test sein.
Bestimmt, bestimmt.
Wir sehen aber auch hier schon, du siehst es hier, an den beiden Kupferteilen.
Also wir haben eine dedizierte GPU und eine dedizierte CPU.
Hier drunter wahrscheinlich CPU, hier drunter GPU.
Gibt es gar nicht so wahnsinnig viel zu sagen.
Was mir hier noch auffällt, wir haben hier noch einen SATA-Anschluss.
Das hier sind wahrscheinlich die Vorbohrungen, wo man dann hier noch eine 2,5 Zoll SSD einbauen könnte.
Und ansonsten, was vielleicht noch zu sagen ist, hier unser I.O.
Eigentlich für einen Mini-PC.
Bis jetzt sieht das eigentlich alles ganz okay aus.
Wir werden das wieder zumachen.
Bevor ich alles anschließ, müssen wir natürlich noch den Rest auspacken.
Hier gibt es noch einen versteckten Boden, wo drunter sich, ganz wichtig, unser Netzteil verbirgt.
Weil wir haben ja gerade gesehen, in dem Mini-PC selber ist ja kein Netzteil.
Macht auf jeden Fall auch einen sehr vertrauten...
China-Chinesen, China-Chinesen-Netzteil.
Ehrlich gesagt, die meisten Bedenken bei diesem Ding hätte ich wahrscheinlich wegen dem Netzteil.
Das ist wahrscheinlich so LC-Power-Niveau.
Weiteres Zubehör drin, und zwar einen SATA-Adapter.
Und hier ist noch die zweite Schiene, um die SSD einzubauen, wo wir gerade schon drüber gesprochen haben.
Da wurde dann alles gedacht von Peter.
So, hier sind wir wieder. Unser Test-Setup ist aufgebaut.
Klar, weil es auch der Support-Peter da alles reingeschmissen hat.
Das erste Mal starten.
Und...
Ah ja, wunderschön. Da ist schon unsere rote Gaming-Beleuchtung.
Dann schauen wir mal.
Also, ehrlich gesagt, würde mich die Beleuchtung eher stören, als dass ich das toll finde.
Ich bin gespannt, ob da ein Betriebssystem drauf ist jetzt.
Ah, okay. Die haben halt wirklich einfach Windows 10 vorinstalliert.
Wenn die Windows 10 vorinstalliert haben, dann bin ich auch gespannt, ob die das aktiv haben.
Bestimmt aktiviert. China-Chinesen-Aktivierung.
Sonst war der eigentlich ziemlich silent.
Also noch nicht an, war auf jeden Fall.
Gut, also, Activation.
Windows 10 Pro wurde auch aktiviert.
Ich gehe jetzt da mal einfach schwer davon aus, dass das nicht 100% legit ist.
Doch, doch, doch. Bestimmt, bestimmt.
Oder will er etwa sagen, bei AliExpress oder die chinesische Windows-Installation wäre nicht legit?
Nein, das kann nicht sein.
Die Beleuchtung ist hier wahrscheinlich zum Einsatz gekommen.
Wahrscheinlich, sobald sich das Ding das erste Mal mit dem Microsoft-Server verbindet,
geht es auf unaktiviert zurück.
So nach dem Motto Fake-Key-Fake-Kram-Erkannt.
Interessant ist, schon mal hier unten haben wir einen Batteriestatus.
Also no battery is detected.
Das ist auch ein Punkt, den habe ich gerade eben gar nicht angesprochen,
als wir den PC aufgemacht haben.
Das sind natürlich keine Desktop-Komponenten.
Ging das schon durch den Chat?
Was?
Wer wurde geploggt?
Wer wurde von Cloudflare geploggt?
Was, wer ist denn das?
Ist das irgendein Krypto-Ding?
Sagt mir gar nichts.
Farmen klingt wie Krypto-Kram.
Ich weiß nicht, was das ist.
Ich traue mich jetzt aber auch nicht so wirklich danach zu suchen im Stream,
weil man weiß nie, was dahinter steckt.
Es ist ein Notebook-Mainboard und es ist eine Notebook-CPU und eine Notebook-GPU natürlich.
Ist nicht schlimm, solange das stimmt, was er gekauft hat.
Jetzt ist die Frage, ob wir dieser Windows-Version vertrauen,
weil hier könnten natürlich auch Keylogger oder...
Also ich würde definitiv selbst neu installieren,
als die China-Chinesen-Version zu verwenden.
Andere Dinge für uns vorinstalliert sein, I don't know.
No risk, no fun, wir ziehen es einfach durch.
Wir installieren mal ganz kurz unsere ganzen Testprogramme
und dann sehen wir uns gleich wieder.
So Leute, also das hat jetzt eine Weile gedauert,
aber wir haben unsere ganzen Benchmarks installiert,
wir haben die Treiber installiert und so weiter
und dabei auch einige Erkenntnisse sammeln können.
Die größte Erkenntnis ist, dass das Ding hier ganz schön laut werden kann
und auch ganz schön heiß wird.
Wir hatten erstmal HW-Info offen,
währenddem wir einfach nur die Spiele runtergeladen haben
und hatten dann durchschnittlich irgendwie 80 bis 90 Grad.
Rein beim Download.
Die hat auch schon ordentlich getrottelt, einfach nur im Windows.
Das ist ordentlich.
Okay, das ist die falsche CPU.
Die war nämlich auch außen auf der Verpackung drauf.
Und zwar ist es der i7-9750H.
Bestellt zur Erinnerung haben wir den 10750H.
Wir wurden also betrogen um eine ganze CPU-Generation vom Peter.
Diese CPU hier...
Ja, das darf man bei AliExpress immer alles nicht so genau nehmen.
Deswegen würde ich auch nie im Leben bei AliExpress
so teuren Kram kaufen, der variabel ist.
Die nehmen das da auch nicht so genau.
Maximalen Toro-Takt von 4,5 Gigahertz, wie man hier sehen kann.
Und die CPU, die wir eigentlich bestellt haben,
eine Generation jünger, hat halt einen Toro-Takt von 5 Gigahertz.
Also wurden wir um 500 Megahertz betrogen.
Das ist natürlich schon ein ordentlicher Unterschied.
Hier einmal unsere iGPU.
Und wenn wir umschalten.
Wie bestellt eine GTX 1650?
Wir haben hier insgesamt 1024 Shader-Einheiten.
Im Desktop-Modell sind es nur 896, glaube ich.
Also knapp 900.
Wir haben hier tatsächlich in der Mobile-Variante mehr Shader,
um den bisschen niedrigeren Takt auszugleichen, einfach.
Also die sollte tatsächlich genau gleich schnell sein wie die Desktop-Variante.
GPU ist die, die wir bestellt haben.
CPU nicht.
Das werden wir später auf jeden Fall mal bei Peter nachfragen.
Und wir gehen direkt mal rein.
Du wirst da doch niemand erreichen, wirklich, oder?
Wir schauen uns an, was die CPU so leistet.
9000er Intel Mobile-CPUs sind echt nicht langsam.
Sollte auch eigentlich der Multicore reichen.
Wir haben eine Punktzahl von 865 Punkten.
Oder zu sagen, es sind halt 865 Punkte.
Stabil?
Stabil, ja. Macht Lust auf mehr.
Macht auf jeden Fall Lust auf 3DMark.
System-Info, komm schon.
Also beim 3DMark, ich meine, wenn der im Windows-Desktop-Betrieb
schon gedrosselt hat, wie sonst was, wird er da jetzt erst recht drosseln.
Das wird langsam wie...
Und hat er vorher wahrscheinlich auch schon.
Wir können uns bei der Gelegenheit, bevor ich jetzt 3DMark starte,
auch noch ganz kurz mal die Werte der SSD anschauen.
Wobei es ja eigentlich eine NVMe-SSD ist.
Also ich glaube, dass die schon schnell ist.
Also knapp 2 GB pro Sekunde.
Also liegt es vielleicht tatsächlich an der mysteriösen Windows-Version,
die hier drauf installiert wurde.
So, was machen wir, Timespy, oder?
Ich glaube, der Advanced-Gaming-PC hatte so 5 FPS 6.
Und hier sind wir für einen Mini-PC eigentlich ordentlich unterwegs,
würde ich sagen.
Ist eine 1650 drin.
Wir haben eine 1650 bestellt.
Was will zu mehr erwarten als die Leistung,
die man von einer 1650 erwarten kann.
Hast du es gerade gesehen? Unsere CPU ist ganz kurz...
Welches Tool?
Boah, was war denn das?
Schau mal.
Das war das Teil, was alle verwenden.
Ich weiß aber gerade nicht, wie es heißt hier.
HW-Info?
Ja.
Auf 90° hochgesprungen.
Und dann hat sie runtergetaktet auf irgendwie 1 Gigahertz
und hat wieder hochgetaktet.
Also, die ist krass am throttlen, die CPU.
Die CPU ist überhitzt wie sonst was.
Die kann den Takt nicht halten.
Die wird extrem heiß.
Das System versucht irgendwie, die CPU bei 60° rumzuhalten.
Was extrem niedrig ist, weil ich meine,
die CPU, die können auch 90° theoretisch ab.
Jetzt haben wir es wieder 86°.
Und dann direkt wieder runter.
Runtergetaktet und wieder 20° weniger.
20° mehr, die springt einfach 20° 80° auf 60° auf 80°.
Wir sind in letzter Zeit öfters mit interessanten Kühlkonzepten
konfrontiert hier auf dem Channel.
Sei es der HP Gaming PC, der einfach...
Also, da kann man jetzt wenig von Kühlung sprechen, oder?
Ich meine, die haben da Lüfter drauf.
Die machen halt überhaupt nicht das, was sie eigentlich machen müssten.
Und der hier, der, naja, hat halt zwei Silent-Lüfter.
Der hat Lüfter, die nix bringen.
Die sind extrem leise, ja.
Ich kann mal mit meinem Mikrofon hin.
Ich weiß nicht, ob man das gehört hat.
Super silent.
Unsere Punktzahl, 3512 Gesamtpunkte, 3379 Grafikpunkte, 4530 CPU-Punkte.
Also an sich eine ganz ausgeglichene Konfiguration.
Ich meine, ist kein High-End-System.
Darüber sind wir uns alle bewusst.
Abgesehen von den Temperaturen bin ich eigentlich ganz zufrieden mit dem Ergebnis.
Deswegen geht es jetzt auch rein in CSGO.
Also, seriously, CS läuft denn wirklich überall drauf?
Professionell unterwegs.
Professionell, wie CS unterwegs gewesen wird.
Undercover, aber...
Das werde ich jetzt auch gleich beweisen, natürlich.
Bestimmt.
Der hat jetzt deinstalliert das Spiel.
Genau.
Also, wir haben so um die 100 FPS.
100 bis 120 würde ich sagen, kann man machen.
Toaster-Test ist bestanden.
Ich meine, an die Klangkulisse muss man sich gewöhnen.
Also, wenn CS...
Wenn es irgendwo einen PC-Bilder schafft, das CS nicht drauf läuft,
dann weißt du schon mal, es ist komplett verkackt worden.
Wir haben F4 gesperrt bei CSGO.
Und wenn du dann im Matchmaking bist und drückst Alt-F4 aus Reflex,
dann nicht so gut für den Rest vom Team.
Also, Fortnite.
Denn heute mal im Moisty-Meyer landen, oder?
Tiltetaus.
Ja, wann ruft er denn Peter an?
Unsere CPU schon wieder runtergetaktet hat auf unter 3 Gigahertz.
Das ruckelt auch immer, wenn es runtertaktet.
Das kannst du gar nicht richtig spielen.
Schreibt mal in die Kommentare.
Tiltet Gang.
Schreibt es in die Kommentare.
So, 80 FPS.
Okay, wann wird Peter angerufen?
Getötet.
Ganz kurz rein in Assassin's Creed.
Moment.
Die können Peter gar nicht mehr anrufen.
Das wird so sein, wie ich gesagt habe.
Da geht keiner dran.
Genau, solche ruckeln.
Minipc-Sicherheit muss noch generell mitlaufen.
Und erst grad zu bleiben, was auch mega-weird ist.
Guck mal, sie haben keinen Platz mehr.
Sie baitet.
Peter, Peter anrufen.
Okay.
Peter rangeht.
Die Nummer ist ja öffentlich.
Falls ihr auch mal bei Peter anrufen möchtet.
Wie viel Uhr haben wir in China?
Peter muss jetzt rangehen.
Wir lassen einfach durchklingen.
So lange, bis Peter rangeht.
Entschuldigung.
Die Telefonnummer ist momentan unangenehm.
Das ist halt eine China-Chinesennummer.
Nummer nicht verfügbar.
Ich glaube, wir wurden gerade geblockt.
Nee, das kann ja nicht sein.
Gut, Leute, das hat anscheinend nicht geklappt.
Aber wir werden nicht aufgeben.
Ich werde auf jeden Fall heute Abend nochmal anrufen.
Was ein Cheat-Bait-Titel, Alter.
Was ein Cheat-Bait-Titel.
Er hat angerufen, ist keiner dran gegangen.
Massive.
Wir werden morgen früh nochmal anrufen.
Wir werden versuchen, den Peter zu erreichen.
Weil mich interessiert ja schon, was er dazu zu sagen hat.
Deswegen, wir rufen da jetzt gleich nochmal an.
Also nicht gleich, sondern jetzt im Video für euch gleich.
Okay, Leute.
Also, nächster Tag und Versuch Nummer 2.
Komm schon, Peter, geh ran.
Peter, Peter, is it you?
Okay, Leute, das war nichts.
Morgen Versuch Nummer 3.
So, Leute, also Tag 3 und Versuch Nummer 3.
Ich habe extra die RTX 3080 Jacke angezogen.
Hoffentlich bringt die Glück.
Ich hätte gesagt, ich ruf jetzt direkt auch an.
Daumen drücken.
Ach, Peter.
Peter, Peter, Peter.
Lasst uns einfach stehen mit unserem Mini-PC.
Nummer nicht verfügbar.
Tja, das war nichts.
Ich habe jetzt bei dem Titel erwartet, da geht zumindest jemand ran.
Und sie sind irgendwo ganz woanders gelandet.
Ich meine, streng genommen ist der Titel korrekt.
Er hat angerufen, hat aber niemand dran bekommen.
Aber trotzdem.
Es ist halt AliExpress, ganz ehrlich.
Also, ich sage euch mal, wie es ist.
Der bestellt die Sachen natürlich bei AliExpress.
Weil er hofft, dass sie nicht dementsprechend oder dementsprechend
darüber ein Video und Content machen kann.
So würde ich es auch machen.
Also, da ist gar nicht die Hoffnung, dass was Ordentliches ankommt.
Weil stellt euch mal vor, das wäre alles top in Ordnung gewesen.
Und Peter wäre auch noch dran gegangen.
Ja, das wäre wahrscheinlich dann kein gutes Video.
So würde ich es wahrscheinlich auch machen, wenn ich eine Art Channel hätte.
Bei Fett-Time.
Ok, was kann man uns als nächstes ankommen?
Warum du nicht genug Freunde hast?
Weil mich Leute nerven, das weiß ich.
Was?
Warum habe ich hier ein Video offen?
Top 10 Rotting Food Timelapses.
Potato.
Ok, wir gucken uns jetzt nicht 15 Minuten an, Leute.
Wir gucken uns...
Ok, was haben wir?
Burger?
Oh.
Das gucken wir nicht an.
Moment, Moment.
Ok, Burger, Kartoffel und Burger.
Ok, das geht zwei Minuten oder so.
Ah, ich fange erstmal abhaltig an zu schimmeln.
Was krabbelt denn da?
Was krabbelt denn da? Da sind Fruchtfliegen jetzt jede Menge, oder?
Nee.
Ok, da ist echt nicht mehr viel übrig.
Ok, Burger, Burger gucken wir uns so an.
Dann...
Auf gehts.
Also der frische Burger, der Schimmel, der andere, der fällt einfach nur in sich zusammen.
Da tut sich einfach gar nichts mehr bei dem anderen.
Da tut sich einfach gar nichts.
Der schrumpft einfach nur.
Ok, ok.
Ok.
Ok, jetzt wirst du wirklich nicht mehr erkennen, was das mal ursprünglich war.
Wie kommen die Mücken in den Glastank rein?
Naja ok, jetzt wissen wir jetzt wissen wir auch wie Burger verrotten.
Gut YouTube, dass du uns das gezeigt hast.
Die Larven sind schon im Essen, das bezweifle ich mal wenn da Sachen wenn das gekocht ist
und sowas.
Tribulon moin, danke für den Zapp, ich weiß nicht das ist was das schockt mich ehrlich
gesagt nicht.
Was ich ekelig finde sind irgendwelche großen Spinnen und sowas, das finde ich ekelig aber
ansonsten.
Findest du es ekelig Essensreste aus dem Spülbecken rauszunehmen?
Ja, sagen wir so es ist jetzt nicht so das ich scharf drauf bin, es ist also es ist nicht
das ich denke oh fuck ich kann da nicht reingreifen aber ich freue mich da jetzt nicht drüber.
Mäßig, mäßig ekelig ja, oh man spielt immer noch übelst smooth, ok was können wir
sonst noch mal gucken, Homelab Build, Building a NAS, schon wieder, Ex Dice Entwickler packt
aus über Battlefield 2042, ok komm wir geben auch mal kleinen Content Creatern eine Chance,
aber erstmal schauen wir uns an was bilden sie denn, ok Moment, das müssen wir ein bisschen
forstgippen weil das meiste wahrscheinlich nicht so spannend ist, ok unsinnig also, Pre-Build
NAS Options, Custom, oh ein Rack Mountain Nest wird gebaut, ist schon mal ein ordentliches
Gehäuse und erstmal das ganze mit ordentlichen Nocturl Lüftern gemodert so muss das sein,
erinnert mich ein bisschen an mein Eigenkonstrukt, erinnert mich ein bisschen an an mein Eigenkonstrukt
hier unten, auch erstmal noch die Nocturl Lüfter drin gewesen, ja 4 HU Gehäuse ist
tatsächlich das angenehmste, oh wo sind wir stehen geblieben, da, I wanna put this rack
into the same room that I'm recording videos like this one, also 4 HU Gehäuse ist tatsächlich
das angenehmste einfach weil da normale Festplatten, äh nicht normale Festplatten, normale Netzteile
reinpassen und normale Netzteile, normale Mainboards, normale Platten und alles, so
I priced out building my own 12 bay hotswappable unit with 10 gigabit for 1600 dollars, ähm
ich weiß nicht wo er das Gehäuse her hat, vielleicht hat er das ja auch von irgendeinem
ausgemusterten Server, wobei die haben da nicht so ein normales Netzteil mount, tja, mal schauen
was hat er für ein Gehäuse, case, ahja, nee das ist unsinnig teuer, alter für nen case,
3, nee, nee, das ist halt das ding, das zeug ist halt wenn du so kaufst einfach echt teuer,
rack mount nass nennt man das nicht einfach storage server, du kannst den nennen wie
du willst, ein storage server ist halt aber so die etwas weit gefasstere Bezeichnung,
bei nem nass ist relativ klar was es macht, das mainboard ist doch super teuer, weiß
ich nicht, weiß ich nicht, keine Ahnung, mainboard, keine Ahnung, ja viel zu teuer
eigentlich, das ist ein mainboard für, ja also die power brauchst du für nass in der
Regel eher nicht, naja das ist, äh sicher, die sind meistens innen drinnen dran geklebt
die Schlüssel, da muss er nochmal gucken ob da wirklich kein Schlüssel dabei ist,
ansonsten muss er den lockpicking lawyer anschreiben, ja wenn er die parts benutzt die er hat dann
ist ok, aber neu kaufen würde ich das nicht, weil die noctua lüfter und so, das kann man
sich natürlich kaufen, ansonsten lohnt sich das nicht, moment, der baut den cpu kühler
zuerst drauf, haben wir nicht letztens in diesem pc zusammenbau video gelernt, dass man den
pc kühler erst wenn alles fertig ist im gehäuse am schluss als allerletztes montiert, erinnert
ihr euch noch an dieses tolle video, ja wir haben im letzten video geguckt wo sie gezeigt
haben wie wird ein pc gebaut und da haben die am ende den kühler reingesetzt, die wasserkühlung
war das auch noch, die haben alles fertig gemacht, das gehäuse fertig, mainboard eingebaut
und haben dann am ende den kühler drauf gesetzt, haben es nicht hinbekommen und haben dann das
video geschnitten und gezeigt so nach dem motto so easy installation wir schneiden jetzt und
jetzt ist es drauf, das waren doch auch die in dem video die sich so das anti dieses statik
armband angezogen haben aber nirgendswo angeschlossen haben, naja naja ich kann nur empfehlen wenn
man 10 gigabit karten haben will sowas da in der richtung zu kaufen und die gibt es
es teilweise schon relativ günstig, wird der k150 euro für eine 10g karte ausgeben,
das war der verge pc bild guide ja genau, aber die on board man muss halt gucken was
es für eine on board 10g karte ist, also ich vermute mal wenn man das wirklich ordentlich
haben will auch mit dementsprechend gutem linux support und so dass es da keine probleme
gibt fährt man wahrscheinlich mit so einer melanox 10g karte besser, ja von den dingern
halte ich ja nix, da bin ich kein großartiger fan von, also ganz im ernst wenn man sich
sowas selbst bauen will und man möchte wirklich so viele platten anschließen dass das on
board nicht reicht dann würde ich mir ein mainboard suchen entweder mit integriertem
mini sas controller hba ja am besten ein mainboard mit einem controller drauf oder
halt irgendeine karte, nicht um da drüber raid zu machen oder so, sondern einfach dass
hotswap richtig funktioniert und solche geschichten, also so diesen billig erweiterungskarten
wenn man das wirklich in so einem storage system einsetzen will, wahrscheinlich wird
es zum größten teil ohne probleme gehen und wahrscheinlich auch meistens keine probleme
machen aber ich bin da trotzdem kein großer fan von
das ist ein wenig auf was heißt wobei man sagen muss gerade bei einem nas mit magnet
fest platten also mit klassischen 3,5 zoll hard drives wenn die am anfang alle gleich
angehen also wenn die anfangen zu spinnen alle gleichzeitig das braucht in der spitze
tatsächlich ein bisschen leistung und wenn es gar so knapp bemisst kann es sein dass
es einfach zu viel ist also insofern so verkehrt ist das gar nicht genau das ist das beste
was du machen kannst ist wenn die dinger einfach der reihe nach hoch fahren
die noctua dinger sind halt teuer aber auch gut
also für eine mass mit vier festplatten ist das echt ein fettes ding was er da gekauft
hat also das ist fast ein wenig oversized für vier festplatten ich meine das ding ist
gerade mal bis hier voll dann nimmst du vielleicht noch ssd cash oder hast du nochmal so viel
frei außerdem sind 18 terabyte das stimmt 18 terabyte sind saumäßig teuer
ich glaube 14 12 oder 14 terabyte ist aktuell glaube so das was preisleistungsmäßig ganz
gut ist ich meine rein gigabyte reines reines gigabyte pro cent ist glaube ich immer noch
irgendwie vier vier terabyte oder so das beste aber
das das steigt da nicht so krass und ich glaube das bleibt bis 14 terabyte ganz gut danach
wird ultra teuer warum die pc karte wenn er nur ich habe keine ahnung hat er nicht
genug sata anschlüsse ich sehe hier nur ein sata anschluss aber hier unten hat er doch
bestimmt noch mehr man sieht es nicht richtig das ist gar kein sata anschluss hier unten
oder das ist irgendwas anderes das in den pin header
versorgung ja du hast schon insofern recht wenn du schon den ganzen aufwand machst und
vielleicht dann auch mit irgendwelchen rate geschichten anfängst
und vielleicht noch eine usv und sowas drinne hast ja also wenn du quasi an allen stellen
es schon rennen und dann gebaut hast warum dann nicht auch beim netzteil hast du schon
irgendwie recht wobei ich halt wirklich sagen muss die fälle wo mal wirklich mir ein netzteil
verreckt ist die kann ich eigentlich fast und selbst wenn ich die zeit beim provider
dazu nehme wo ich viel im rechenzentrum war die kanzler ist wirklich die kann ich dann
zwar nicht mehr an einer hand abzählen ja aber das ist nicht oft gewesen lass es mal
in meinen ganzen in den ganzen jahren wo ich dort gearbeitet habe und auch oft im rechenzentrum
war lass es mal keine ahnung lass es mal 10 netz 10 15 netzteile gewesen sein und ich
war 2000 von 2007 bis 2012 da also keine ahnung ich habe irgendwie sagen wir mal sagen wir
mal 10 bis 15 netzteile gewechselt in fünf jahren also das hält sich doch in grenzen
wo da was kaputt geht wohlgemerkt das sind dann aber auch keine china chinesen netzteile
gewesen sondern teure wo du dann bei ibm anrufen musstest damals noch und die fru nummer durchgeben
wer von euch hatte auch schon mal die die ehre mit ibm zu telefonieren und die fru nummer
raussuchen zu müssen und dann zu sagen ja ich kann da jetzt nicht drauf gucken was
das für eine fru nummer hat weil die fru nummer steht innen drauf und ich kann das
system kann ich ausschalten das war immer abenteuer mit ibm
ich sehe
mark ishii hat auch so was schon gemacht fru nummer
aber hatte ich das zeug naja wie gesagt ich habe da in fünf jahren oder so vielleicht
10 bis 15 netzteile gewechselt und ich bin jeden tag morgens rundgang durchs rechenzentrum
durch die rechenzentren muss man ja sagen rundgang gemacht in allen kontrolliert auf
auf warnleuchten monitoring ich war damals sogar lange zeit sogar für unser von unseren
agios monitoring zuständig also ganz im ernst netzwerkfehler sind relativ selten solange
es nicht lc power china chinesen netzteile sind
euer alter zahn switch ist gestorben wir hatten mal einen zahn wir hatten mal einen zehntausend
euro zahn switch als tür als tür stopper bei uns nachdem er ausgebaut war hätte man
vielleicht lieber auf ebay verkaufen sollen
das ist auch eine fancy ganz ehrlich das ist auch so eine fancy bezeichnung für steckdosenleiste
im endeffekt distribution unit ja steckdosenleiste steckdosenleiste ich sagte es ist steckdosenleiste
gut es ist nicht eine simple steckdosenleiste aber es ist im prinzip eine steckdosenleiste
wo will er denn 24 her bekommen aus der norm ok wie ist es bei den amis was haben die amis
maximal was dürfen die was darfrs noch so eine adi steckdose maximal holen die am 110
volt glaube ich oder oder 100 100 oder 110
das heißt du kannst da also du kannst da nicht ganz das machen was du bei uns bei uns
3,6 glaube ich oder ja reicht auch es ist eine steckdosenleiste mit snmp und ssh aber es ist
steckdosenleiste die sollen das funktionieren mit 220 volt 24 ampere 5,2 kilowatt wie soll
das klappen das ist doppelte von dem was da rauskommt wie macht man das denn die
drives der reihe nach einschalten das ist relativ einfach wenn du einen halbwegs
gescheiten controller hast macht er das von sich aus oder man kann es einschalten wenn es
ein on-board controller ist kannst du es meistens im bios machen oder oder aber du sorgst dafür
dass sie dass sie dinger gar nicht eingeschaltet werden sondern erst wenn du das betriebssystem
startest die quasi diesen wake-up impuls kriegen und dann kannst du es darüber handeln lassen
ach so aber das kann natürlich sein
ne ne so funktioniert das nicht so funktioniert das nicht wenn du zwei steck wenn du irgendwo
zwei stecker einsteckst hast du auch nicht zwei mal hast du nicht 240 volt so ist so funktioniert
das nicht das ist weiterhin 120 ich gehe einfach mal davon aus dass das eher das ist was die was
der chat sagt dass das wohl die angaben sind was es in der spitze verkraften könnte im zweifelsfall
we don't have any nema plugs or nema receptacles on the was sind nemo plucks
pdu that i bought so instead you either have to buy new kakona zeug or a cable that's going to
convert from nema to the sea variants it was for me i bought new cables just so i could get
so for now my power problem is solved beyond power distribution and storage the next order of
business is networking i have a lot of devices with varying speeds and the needs of those speeds
but i've got a solid four ish machines that i'd like to switch
ich vermute nämlich mal dass ich ganz großen abstand von diesem switch nehmen würde sagt
mir mein bauchgefühl gerade so ja preislich geht es ist aber jetzt nicht so der absolute
wahnsinn unmanaged acht port ja ich mein das ist jetzt nicht so schlecht preislich einfach na ja
das ist ein acht port acht port 10 g switch so viele gibt es davon auch nicht das ist denke ich
ganz okay wobei ich mir definitiv lieber den mikrotik switch kaufen würde in dem fall wenn
es um günstige günstige segmente geht zum beispiel also mikrotik hat einen relativ günstigen vier
port 10 g switch komplett managt mit router os drauf und wahrscheinlich auch noch mehr
mittlerweile ich bin ja da nicht mal so auf dem laufenden wahrscheinlich würde ich einen
anderen switch nehmen oder oder aber du gibst 200 euro mehr aus und du bekommst einen zwölf
port sfp plus und vier port kupfer zehn gigabit es ist auch schon fragwürdig dass es das ist
kupfer port sind weil gerade im zehn gigabit bereich wo ich sagen zumindest so bei meiner
sache hier ist es eher sfp plus also ich habe überall sfp plus zehn gigabit außer bei mir
im desktop bei mir im desktop ist es der tp link ist unmanaged der der bei mir am desktop ist es
eine zehn gigabit kupfer letzte karte aber der rest ist alles sfp plus so gucken wir mal weiter
kann man machen ich meine es ist für mich also wild zu haben damit wahrscheinlich einfach tun
ist possible or at least financially reasonable but the more the merrier i have lots of switches one
pretty old switch that is like a hundred megabits per second you know and gigabit only and it only if
i actually need that speed okay weiter ich will eigentlich auch sehen sliding rails are super cool
but either extremely expensive and still needing to be like retrofitted to the case that you intend
to use i will er muss halt ehrlich sagen so richtig cool ist halt ein server beziehungsweise
ein rack und server mit rackbauweise eigentlich auch nur wenn du ihn sinnvoll rausziehen kannst
das ist halt der vorteil davon irgendwo wenn du den server nicht richtig raus ich kann ich habe
sie aber mir im rack auch nicht so ich habe leisten drinne aber wirklich wirklich bis zum
ende rausziehen kannst du es nicht say some cases and equipment do come with quality rails is not
like that they don't exist but it's just pretty rare it seems and then the ones ja wenn du dir
fertige server hardware kaufst da gibt es dann auch dabei wobei ich weiß gar nicht ob die wirklich
dabei geliefert werden weil zumindest bei uns waren immer dabei aber es kommt wahrscheinlich
darauf an was unser einkauf damals bestellt hat die schienen waren schon wirklich nice muss man sagen
also ich mochte die ibm schienen nicht so weil bei ibm schienen muss es die surfer immer reinheben
bei also du musstest die surfer so reinklipsen und bei hp war es glaube ich damals da wurde das
dran geschraubt das fand ich deutlich praktischer
unbelievable expensive or just way too untrustworthy to risk multi-thousand dollar machines falling on
yet more multi-thousand dollar machines in a cascading fashion so to help me sleep at night
i went with something i can actually wenn ich daheim bauen würde wir den server e ganz unten ins rack
machen da kann man es einfach ausziehen dann auf die erde und gut ist entweder den server ganz unten
oder je nachdem wie fett die usw ist die usf ganz unten halt in der regel wie immer das schwerste
unten just put my faith in and sind das sind das sind das eigentlich hot swap fähige wechsel
dingsbums da hat er da was zugesagt i got these universal rails from star tech for things like the
switches and stuff like that ear mounting is totally fine same thing with like the pdu that's ear
mounted but for heavier things like the nazi ne moment der steckt ne doch passt doch
das hier ist die platte und hier wird es dann eigentlich also die platte steckt hier quasi in
dem rahmen drin oder oder ist das hier noch das ende der platte ne ne ist es nicht
das hier ist der das ist quasi der anschluss vom rahmen und das ist die platte oder mir auch immer
ich erkenne jetzt gar nicht genau wir haben unsere usw oben ja im rechenzentrum kann man das auch
machen ich rette jetzt von so einem einzelnen freistehenden offenen rack daheim da würde
ich die schwersten sachen immer unten hin machen we want something that is trustworthy for the
software side of the nazi i've gone with true nazi 13 i put the operating system on to wobei ich
auch nicht wüsste warum man in dem rechenzentrum die usw oben hin machen weil die usw da eigentlich
eher zentral ist die solid state drives for redundancy and then i've got another 240 gigabyte
ssd for cash i found a super helpful video okay weiter i'm left in case it's like playable to
like doing for you and it just hat schon mal ein gutes rack ordentliches rack allerdings mit
nichts drinnen okay da oben ist das switch okay dann made me feel like what would i need also an
stelle des switches hätte ich wahrscheinlich eher lass uns mal kurz schauen was die was die
neu ist haben ups also das ist die billig das ist die billig variant plus zwei man muss sagen die
benahmung bei mikrotik geräten ist tatsächlich ganz gut das hier sind die 1 gigabit ports das
sind die sfp plus ports und das sind die sfp ports also sprich man kann sich da anhand des
namens tatsächlich was zusammen reiben also das brauchen wir alles nicht
ja also crs steht für routerswitch und das ist ccr ist glaube ich cloud router oder sowas also
wichtig ist man muss gucken hier nach s nach s plus so also hier haben wir beispielsweise 4s plus das
ist ein bisschen weniger als haben will er will 8s plus haben das ist das ist das ist noch schneller
all das ist ordentlich das ist 100 das ist 100 gig oder 40 40 oder 25 g und dann irgendwie
2 mal 100 natürlich schon ordentlich das also den hier da habe ich auch daheim den finde ich gut
preisleistungsmäßig 150 euro kriegst du vier ports sfp plus 10 gigabit und ein manage port
beziehungsweise poe import oder ein oder halt auch einfach als ein gigabit port benutzt war
switch mit dualen netzwerk mit mit mit dual stromanschluss also 200 netzteile drinne warum
ich auf mikro weil die preisleistungsmäßig absolut poxen die funktionen sind gut und es
kostet nicht viel ja die sind managt das erkennst du daran weil es ein crs ist ein cloud router
switch die haben router os drauf die anderen sind auch managt haben wir nur switch os drauf
und switch os ist halt was funktionen angeht ein bisschen eingeschränkt dafür switch vollkommen
ok router os ist halt von der bedienung her ein bisschen pepega an manchen stellen ich
meine gerade die wlan konfig ist schon unnötig kompliziert und du kannst auf drei verschiedene
arten zeug anlegen ist es naja hier sowas das wäre das wäre gut gewesen für ihn kuck
sowas hier acht pox acht pox den habe ich doch hier sogar stehen oder moment den habe
ich habe ich den hier nicht sogar neben stehen was habe ich hier stehen ach nee hier neben
habe ich den kleinen stehen mit 2 mit 2 sfp plus css 610 ja das war für ihn gut gewesen
natürlich sind das sachen nach oben wieder wieder keine grenzen gesetzt ja aber da wäre
doch gut gewesen für ihn komplett css komplett managt kann er sogar ein paar simple firewall
regeln drauf machen falls er irgendwie mal was blocken will das verkraftet die cpu auch
was bedeutet managt an managt in der regel bedeutet managt dass der switch ein web interface
hat oder ein kommando zeilen zugang wo du sachen drauf konfigurieren kannst das ist
erstmal unabhängig davon was der switch für features bietet ja also du hast quasi eine
management schnitt stelle dann ist er managt und wenn du das ding einfach nur an strom
anschließen kann und kannst und er macht dann halt was der machen soll und du kannst ihn
aber nicht beeinflussen dann ist er unmanaged also 99 prozent der switche und sachen die
die leute daheim haben in der richtung sind unmanaged weil die leute wollen den switch
anschließen dann irgendwie ihren fernseher und ihren was weiß ich was schließt sie da
noch dran an ihren fernsehen ihren video streaming dings ihren desktop rechner sonst
was schließen die das daran an und es ist gut normale switches sind ja unmanaged auch
vollkommen ok weil die machen halt nix außer das was ein switch machen soll switchen so
unmanaged heißt ja erstmal nur dass du ein management interface hast früher musstest
du dabei per kabel dran mittlerweile ist es natürlich alles remote entweder per web interface
oder per kommando zeile oder meistens heutzutage sogar beides manche bieten auch zentrale management
interfaces an da kannst du dann deine switches drin registrieren und da drüber zentral managen
ja wenn du mal sehen willst wie sowas aussieht das ist jetzt allerdings eine löse das ist
jetzt gut als das ist ziemlich umfangreich komplex kann alles mögliche aber nur dass
du es gesehen hast so sicher ach ich kann es canceln alles gut so so muss das aussehen
genau ja also da siehst du was hier alles einstellen kannst ja du kannst dir die statistiken
von dein interfaces angucken du kannst wie land anlegen du kannst vx land chat was war
denn das noch mal ist das ist das ist das interviewe land routing oder irgendwie sowas
wie wieland aber über ipa das ist das ding was der was hetz was hetzner da macht weil
das warum das routing da so ppega ist teilweise so du kannst interface bonding machen du kannst
sogar mittlerweile sogar wireguard vpn direkt machen modem deine deine netzwerk ports zusammenfassen
zu kleineren virtuellen netzwerk ports du kannst ganz viele ip settings mannus firewall
settings aus dem dns servos der cp server also router us kann alles unter der haube
ist es in lilux aber halt mit einem web interface so und das ding ist halt das management interface
für diesen switch router us ist allerdings auch wirklich ausgesprochen komplex zu konfigurieren
zwar es gibt auch geräte die eigentlich ganz so verwirrendes interface haben die dann aber
vielleicht auch nicht so viel können also wenn ich auf meinen router daheim gehe dann
sieht das genauso aus cisco ist wesentlich einfacher ehrlich gesagt ich habe ja mit
cisco nicht so viel am hut ich habe aber mal ein cc na gemacht vor ganz ganz langer zeit
ich finde das cisco cli tatsächlich einfacher das ist irgendwie selbst erklärender er und
eigentlich für den sup welche günstigsten und günstige nur nach 15 switch empfiehlt
so einfach für fernsehkonsole aber nimm dir den gigabit nimm dir den billigsten tp link
gigabit switch von amazon und fertig da musst du dir um managet und unmanaget keine gedanken
machen du willst den nicht managen nimm den billigsten den du finden kannst ja nimm mal
nimm mal den acht port dann hast du noch genug platz nimm irgendwas ganz billiges hier es
reicht für deine zwecke vollkommen aus poe brauchst du nicht 20 euro switch fertig aus
ist reicht da für dicke
also micro sense kenne ich nicht du kannst ja du kannst da drauf aber ich zeig ich zeig
dir mal du kannst darauf feierwollen regeln anlegen aber
du kannst darauf feierwollen regeln anlegen auf deinem switch klingt erst mal bescheuert
aber es ist halt es ist halt ein gerät mit hardware zum switchen drauf ist kein reiner
switch deswegen auch immer diese sache layer 3 switch ihr kennt ja ihr kennt mich ja layer
3 switch gibt es nicht es gibt switche die mehr verstehen oder es gibt geräte es gibt
geräte die haben switching komponenten eingebaut die noch mehr können aber switching an sich
hat mit layer 3 nichts zu tun sowas ist das hier ja auch weil das ist im prinzip ein layer
7 gerät du kannst ja teilweise sogar hier hatte tp filtern und sowas mit hardware die
es eben erlaubt relativ effizient frames zu switchen das heißt nicht dass es ein switch
ist und der sonst nichts außer layer 2 versteht ja guck du kannst dir feierwollen regeln anlegen
allerdings musst du da ein bisschen aufpassen wenn du dort es übertreibst mit feierwollen
und du wirklich also nehmen wir mal den hier nehmen wir mal den hier zum beispiel ja das
ist in 24 port gigabit 2 port 10 gigabit switch und er hat als cpu er hat eine 800 megahertz
frag mich nicht speziell arm 32 cpu die cpu selbst wird beim switchen kaum belastet da
ist extra hardware drauf die das macht die hardware kannst du auch über das web interface
das kannst du hier machen kannst du das auch konfigurieren ja also du siehst beispielsweise
auch wie wo wie wo welche ports gemapt sind und das sieht man bei denen auch irgendwo
im ja in den testing results siehst du es und du siehst auch irgendwo im irgendwo im
handbuch siehst du es auch so aber alles was darüber hinaus geht also sprich alles was
nicht direkt gezwitscht werden kann über die switching hardware zum beispiel nur zwei
britches anlegst und ein switch quasi so virtuell nochmal teilst jetzt und dann von einer zur
anderen rüber willst so dass es nicht über die switching hardware gehen kann sondern
über die cpu gehen muss dann gehen die dinge halt relativ schnell in die knie weil eine
eine 800 megahertz arm 32 cpu ist jetzt halt auch jetzt nicht der wahnsinn also wenn du
jetzt ein wire guard vpm machst darfst du nicht erwarten dass du damit gigabyte nicht ich weiß
gigabit gigabitweise speed bekommst selbst wenn der switch per 10 gig angeschlossen ist ehrlich
gesagt keine ahnung wie viel du hier maximal wire guard rüber machen kannst aber wenn ich
wenn ich mal raten müsste würde ich sagen 30 40 megabyte vielleicht und dann ist die cpu
wahrscheinlich am anschlag also alles was hier dann über die cpu laufen muss ist dann nicht das
ist nicht dafür gedacht also das ist nicht hierfür als high du kannst damit zwar vpn machen aber das
ist nicht als high performance vpn gateway geeignet nur weil es geht und mit firewall regeln ist es
genauso gerade wenn du layer sieben wenn du layer sieben filter oder sowas machst das muss das
muss halt von der cpu gemacht werden das ist nicht wir switchen jetzt die frames von dem ersten
port auf den zweiten port oder von port 5 auf port 15 was relativ schnell über die switching chips
gemacht werden kann das muss wirklich von der cpu gemacht werden also sprich wenn du wenn du hier
firewall regeln hast da muss wirklich reingeguckt werden ok frame da ist ein ip paket drinne
absender ip stimmt sonst wie dann die regeln matchen und dann also man kann jetzt zwar viel
also was ich sagen will ist man kann jetzt zwar viel mit machen aber man muss trotzdem gucken was
man sich für geräte kauft also hier kauft man sich wirklich einen switch einen switch der zwar das
große router os drauf hat mit dem du das auch dort alles einstellen kannst aber performance
technisch ist es halt für den arsch wenn du da wenn du da vpn oder viele firewall regeln und
alles mögliche darüber machen willst ist dir halt die cpu mit 800 megahertz und einer ziel
ist halt vorbei so also da musst du schon gucken und wenn man jetzt hier zum beispiel mal den schaut
bei den bei den routern das css steht für klut kluter für cloud router switch steht das glaube
ich sein kluter das ist das was die china chinesen zu viel in die essen rein machen
ja wenn man jetzt hier mal beispielsweise bei den bisschen bei den bisschen fetteren guckt ja bei
den cloud routern und du schaust mal was da hardware technisch drinne ist da wirst du feststellen
ach guck mal der hat 16 kerne mit 2 gigahertz da kannst du schon mehr machen was vpn und
firewall regeln angeht er hat ein bisschen mehr wums als der andere man muss halt gucken ja man
kriegt beim mikrotik kriegst du ziemlich genau das was du bezahlst aber man darf sich jetzt nicht
abschrecken lassen für den heimbereich ja also es ist nicht so als hat dieser switch probleme mit
dieser anzahl an firewall regeln oder so das ist kein problem damit kommt das klar ich habe da auch
irgendwie 25 oder so drinne aber weil ich habe ja auch ich habe ja ich habe ja einen hex guck mal
was bei mir drinne ist ex poe habe ich bei mir daheim als router und er hat auch eine 800 mega
als tp guck also in meinem router ist im prinzip das gleiche drin wobei es andere ist eine andere
cpu und der kommt damit auch klar mit dem ganzen krempel ja aber so sieht es aus
dass das würde tatsächlich zusammenpassen ja
das ist das ist tatsächlich so ja es ist cool es ist cool logisch jetzt müsstest du
müsstest du sagen es ist es ist es ist es ist gut so zu sagen ach block diagram ja genau stimmt
stimmt stimmt die haben sowas zeige ich zeige euch das mal 3 2 das ding block diagram hier
genau hier siehst du wie die das intern angeschlossen haben also sprich alles
alles was zwischen diesen pots geht wie darf ich das jetzt interpretieren
das hier sind das hier sind einfach nur die ports das sind einfach nur die ports also sprich alles
was direkt geswitcht werden kann zwischen diesen ports ist schnell also sprich alles was auf layer
2 passiert also auf so frame ebene ist schnell sobald du aber irgendwie reingucken musst dann
musst du hier über die cpu erstens ist das ding deutlich langsamer angebunden hier und du musst
halt erst einmal den kram verarbeiten hier drauf dementsprechend ist es ja dass das also
dann ist klar da kannst du nicht von dort nach dort 10g machen wenn du die feierball regel irgendwie
dazwischen packen willst muss man sich halt vorher angucken
was sagt ihr so zu blazer da können wir ein video angucken ich mag blazer nicht ich bin
sie scharf wenn aber ich mag blazer nicht liegt hauptsächlich daran dass so ewig lange ladezeiten
hast weil die irgendwie 8 18 mb mono runtime runterladen müssen weil die garbage collection
nicht richtig funktioniert und du halt immer noch die komplette runtime brauchst vielleicht
ändert sich das mit dort net 7 oder dort net 8 weiter mal schauen ich bin da skeptisch also
bis dahin war blazer einfach nur sehr schwergewichtig und dazu auch noch relativ langsam also blazer war
nicht mein fall so wir können video dazu angucken weil wir sind ja eh durch nicht blazer blazer
gucken wir uns das an feier schipp hat nämlich in video gemacht zu blazer
wenn wir das gerade als thema haben lass uns das doch mal angucken blazer aui framework
for building frontend web applications with html css and not javascript but c-sharp by
leveraging the power of web also müsste mir ja eigentlich richtig gut gefallen weil weil
ich sie scharfen oder net fan bin aber hat man nicht wir haben uns das übrigens auch mal
wir haben uns das auch mal vor jahren angeguckt als es ganz neu war doch in visual studio keckel
it's able to eliminate javascript from your frontend stack it was created at microsoft
in 2018 by steve sanderson the developer famous for creating knockout js years earlier just
like react and other modern ui libraries you build components called razor components that
encapsulate parts of what makes blazer special is its ability to blur the lines between client
and server thanks to wasm you can run c-sharp code with your favorite dotnet libraries in
the browser or alternatively run your client side code on the server and staff is back
das darf man nicht vergessen es gibt ja vor blazer gibt es zwei verschiedene betriebsmodi
server side blazer und client side blazer server side blazer schickt über eine websocket
verbindung den den ui state hin und her keine ahnung ich weiß nicht also ich bin kein großer
blazer fan auch wenn ich dotnet und c-sharp mag aber blazer ich meine man muss ja auch
nicht alles geil finden ich mag maui beispielsweise auch überhaupt nicht
und mittlerweile ist es so schlimm die leute fangen ja schon an blazer und maui zu kombinieren
hat man dann hat man zwei sachen zusammen die naja irgendwie kreppi sind jetzt vor realtime
communication in addition blazer components are capable of running on any platform with
dotnet maui you can reuse your code natively on ios android or desktop now if you're not
convinced c-sharp can get the job done by itself it can easily interrupt with javascript on both
the client and server to get started and install visual studio with asp by net capabilities then
generate a new blazer web assembly project the root of your application contains a router in
the app dot razor file notice how it's structured with a variety of built-in components like router
and layout view that don't need to be explicitly imported like a javascript app now create a new
page by adding a razor component to the pages directory at the top of that file
eigentlich müssen wir das mal wieder ausprobieren vielleicht ist es ja mittlerweile viel besser als
noch vor drei jahren rektiv to specify the url pattern benutzt jemand blazer von euch regelmäßig
und wenn ja was wie ist das so mittlerweile add a title using a built-in razor component or simply
add some plain html here but now it's time to add some reactive state to this application which
can be accomplished with the code directive which allows us to write logic with the industrial
strength reliability of c-sharp define a property like count then use it in the template with the
at symbol the value is reactive so anytime it changes the template will rerender we can add a
method to the code to increment the count then bind it to a button as the on click event handler
now to make the component look pretty add a matching css file and all the styles here will be
scoped to that component now when it comes to sharing logic and state between components blazer
has dependency injection built in which allows you to write a class in one place then inject it
into any component using the inject directive in addition when you add a component to the share
directory it can be used instantly throughout the entire application das ist das ist irgendwo
doch halbwegs elegant gemacht aber ich bin damit nicht warm geworden and not only runs on the web
but virtually any native platform now use dotnet run to compile the web assembly and view your web
app in the browser this has been blazer in 100 seconds hit the like button if you want to see
what the performance is now the last time I looked at it was really really lame and it
was really fat massive people fat when you had to download it as I said complete mono
run time you had to download that was nothing that was really nothing there we have the video
noch mehr rex na ist ja gut so angucken stop using abt ne heim automatisierung
ich weiß nicht
36 minuten kann ich mir jetzt nicht angucken hat letztendlich im chat eine gepostet
schon esoterik javascript angeschaut ist javascript nicht an sich schon relativ esoterik
wenn ich wenn ich da solche dinger sehe aber ich muss sagen javascript hat sich die letzten
jahre doch zum besseren gewendet also javascript ich muss ganz ehrlich ich muss sagen javascript
mache ich mittlerweile ganz gern also neben c-sharp und ruby finde ich mag ich javascript auch wobei
ruby kann es halt aktuell nichts mal machen weil rails kein mehr interessiert und ruby an sich
halt auch unbedeutend geworden ist also ich mache doch kannst du mich machen javascript
mittlerweile eins ganz gern du kannst aber auch nichts anderes machen außer javascript web
technisch was willst du was willst du machen ja gut c++ ja das das ist das ist ja alles
javascript nur das teils gibt noch mal eine richtige portion komplexität obendrauf packt
ich habe letztens gesehen da hat irgendeiner in einem war das der regex engine irgendeiner
hat eine komplette regex engine in type script templates programmiert oder sowas ganz abgedreht
das shit fast fast schon so schlimm wie c++ templates das ist das ist wirklich nicht schlecht also
browserentwicklung ist mittlerweile ja ertragbar also man kann das schon machen das macht auch
macht auch zum größten teil spaß ganz ganz im gegensatz zu c++ und konsorten also javascript
hat sich die letzten jahre wirklich in die bessere in die gute richtung entwickelt man die haben noch
viele oldschool api wo man sich fragt wo aus welcher zeit kommen die gerade das einiges noch
nicht erst irgendwie fähig ist ist halt auch pains jam aber ok ich meine es ist halt der browser die
können da nicht einfach sachen ausbauen weil du kannst davon ausgehen egal was mal in deinem
browser eingebaut war irgendjemand verwendet das und du kannst halt nicht entfernen
stable diffusion auf github sagt mir nix sollte ich eigentlich danach suchen können
jetzt wenn man das rechts anklickt das da
wie funktioniert das jetzt text to image das heißt du sagst du sagst ihm was
der machen soll und dann macht er dir ein bild raus aber das ist cool
das ist tatsächlich cool das können wir das probieren wir mal im nächsten stream
aus nicht jetzt weil jetzt muss ich mal ganz dringend aufs klo das probieren wir aus das
ist tatsächlich kann ich weiß nicht ob sich fürs ab für thumbnail so gut eignet
müssen wir mal ausprobieren
ich probiere es mal aus probiere ich probiere das mal aus demnächst
ich habe so viele tabs auf auf dem zweiten browser dass es nicht mal mehr dass ich dass
ich nicht mal mehr neuen tabs neue tabs öffnen kann also leute ich werde jetzt aufgehen ich
muss mal ganz dringend aufs klo vielleicht gucken wir uns heute abend battlefield 2042 season 2 an
nächste stream weiß ich noch nicht genau wie gesagt vielleicht gucken wir uns heute abend
season 2 an aber verlasst euch mal nicht so sehr drauf ich weiß nicht ob ich bock drauf
habe mein bock auf battlefield hält sich echt in grenzen aktuell wir sehen uns nächsten stream
leute machts gut bis dann see you